l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
sur le thème Comment massifier la
rénovation thermique je vous rappelle
que la Conférence des Présidents fixe à
deux minutes la durée maximale de chaque
question et de chaque réponse
nous commençons par le groupe écologiste
nupet madame evaas
pour deux questions
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ces derniers jours de jeunes
militants de dernière rénovation on
multiplié les actions pour vous demander
d'engager dès maintenant un grand plan
de rénovation thermique leur geste
désespéré n'a qu'un seul but sauver
l'humanité de l'effondrement vers lequel
elle s'avance aveuglément et il vous
interpelle car vous n'avez visiblement
pas pris la mesure de l'enjeu la
question du président de la République
lors de ses vœux qui aurait pu prédire
la crise climatique démontre sa
déconnexion totale des enjeux
environnementaux faut-il rappeler que
les écologistes depuis René Dumont en
1974 et les scientifiques depuis le
premier rapport du GIEC en 1990 ne cesse
d'alerter sur le dérèglement climatique
nous devons vous devez réagir maintenant
et prendre le virage écologique et la
mère des batailles c'est la rénovation
thermique et disons-le clairement il
serait illusoire de croire que le défi
de la rénovation thermique puisse être
relevé sans moyens financiers conséquent
et c'est l'objet de ma première question
le rapport Sichel indique qu'il faudrait
9,3 milliards d'euros sur 10 ans pour
traiter la seule question des passoires
thermiques I for see estime quant à lui
qu'il faudrait 8,8 milliards d'euros par
an pour la rénovation thermique des
seuls logements privés 10 milliards si
l'on englobe les logements sociaux et
les bâtiments tertiaires tous les
rapports convergent donc vers un besoin
de financement de 9 à 10 milliards
d'euros par an pourquoi alors
n'avez-vous fixé le budget de ma prime
rénov en 2023 qu'à 2,5 milliards d'euros
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir augmenté même un
peu alors que la majorité de l'Assemblée
nationale avait voté un amendement
portant ce budget à 9 milliards pourquoi
alors que vous avez consacré 14
milliards d'euros à la baisse des impôts
de production des entreprises ne pas en
mobiliser la moitié 7 milliards
polarisation thermique alors qu'il
s'agit d'un enjeu écologique majeur pour
protéger les Français contre le
dérèglement climatique et la flambée des
prix d'énergie
merci Madame SAS monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
evassas permettez-moi de commencer en
vous souhaitant à toutes et à toutes à
toutes et à tous pardon une très belle
année
2023 pleine de réussite pour vous et
pleine de travaux pour pour les députés
et vous remercier aussi d'avoir mis
cette séance de rentrée sur ce sujet
aussi important qu'est la massification
de la rénovation thermique d'abord oui
vous avez raison rénover les bâtiments
et est une priorité est une priorité
portée par le gouvernement et une
priorité que nous partageons
vous le savez
oui il est possible de critiquer ma
prime rénov et estimée qu'aujourd'hui le
budget n'est pas suffisant mais la
réalité de la filière fait que cette
capacité à dépenser plus de 2 milliards
d'euros en 2023 et déjà une capacité
extrêmement importante les chantiers qui
ont été mis en œuvre précédemment c'est
1,5 millions de chantiers l'ensemble de
ces gestes souvent des monogestes et ça
fera partie du chantier qu'on devra
mener par la suite c'est à dire une
rénovation plus performante puis plus
globale représente en gros l'économie
les économies d'énergie d'une ville
équivalente à la ville de Lyon donc
cette méthode est déjà extrêmement
importante elle a mis dans la tête de
nos concitoyens l'écogestes cette
massification a permis de dépasser un
certain nombre de de freins et nous
allons travailler tant à continuer la
rénovation de l'habitat individuel mais
aller plus loin dans cette dans
l'accompagnement notamment de l'habitat
collectif parce que il n'y aurait pas de
sens de faire de la rénovation seulement
individuelle mais il faut aller plus
loin sur la rénovation collective il
s'agit bien évidemment d'être attentif
et de se donner les moyens et je pense
que les échanges que nous aurons cet
après-midi ne permettront de compléter
je vous remercie madame SAS pour une
seconde question oui merci présidente
monsieur le ministre ma deuxième
question portera c'est la structuration
de la filière justement rénovation
thermique l'objectif en matière de
rénovation thermique vous l'avez fixé
ces deux porter l'ensemble du parc de
logements au niveau BBC Bâtiment Basse
Consommation en 2050 pour cela il faut
atteindre dès maintenant le rythme de
370 000 rénovations globales par an puis
700 000 à partir de 2030 or la France
est en train de manquer complètement ses
objectifs le rythme aujourd'hui n'est
que de 32000 rénovations globales par an
à peine 5% des dossiers de ma prime
rénov pourquoi parce que les ménages ne
sont pas assez soutenus dans ces projets
complexes et coûteux il faut donc les
accompagner les aider à financiers mais
aussi leur permettre de trouver des
artisans vous nous opposez parfois vous
venez de le faire à l'instant que la
filière n'est pas prête à absorber le
rythme de travaux nécessaires nous
partageons en partie ce constat le
rapport Menier millefer évoque des
besoins en main d'oeuvre qui votre x 2
le rapport rénovant estime qu'il
faudrait créer 93 000 emplois dans cette
filière qui n'en compte aujourd'hui que
192.000 or le nombre d'élèves et
d'apprentis dans ces métiers à diminuer
de 25% en disant ma question est donc la
suivante qui attendez-vous pour
construire avec les professionnels du
secteur une feuille de route qui
renforce la rémunération et
l'attractivité de ces métiers qui
accélère la formation au métier du
bâtiment notamment via le programme
febab et qui développe la labellisation
des entreprises aujourd'hui très
insuffisantes puisque seul 80 d'entre
elles sont qualifiées en offre globale
de rénovation la rénovation énergétique
est un grand et beau projet pour la
France c'est le défi de notre génération
un défi enthousiasmant créateur d'emploi
et de pouvoir de vivre mais aussi une
responsabilité historique car c'est
aujourd'hui que la France doit prendre
le virage écologique demain il sera trop
tard
merci Madame SAS monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
plusieurs plusieurs parties à votre
réponse oui pour pouvoir engager un plan
de rénovation de l'habitat on a besoin
de développer l'accompagnateur Renov et
cette stratégie est en oeuvre avec le
développement du service public France
rénov pour que chacun lorsqu'il aura un
projet puisse être accompagné dans le
choix à la fois de la nature des travaux
et aller plus loin que que le simple
geste bien évidemment et ensuite dans le
choix des artisans vous le savez pour
pouvoir répondre aux obligations et
toucher les aides ma prime rénov il faut
que les entreprises soient qualifiées
RGE et ce chantier a été
regardé lors des Assises du bâtiment
lancé par le ministre Bruno Le Maire
auquel mon ministère a aussi participé à
un certain nombre de sujets ont été
évoqués à la fois avec la Fédération
française du bâtiment et la CAPEB pour
contribué à la formation des entreprises
réfléchir à l'accession au label RGE
notamment avec des chantiers puisque
pour avoir ce label RGE il est aussi
possible maintenant d'être sur un
certain nombre de chantiers de chantiers
de suite et ensuite avoir cette capacité
à continuer à mener des chantiers donc
ça reste cette expérimentation a été
prolongée dans le cadre des Assises pour
pouvoir développer
plus d'artisans capables de suivre ces
chantiers bien évidemment il faudra être
attentif notamment et on en parlait tout
à l'heure à l'habitat collectif c'est
des chantiers qui sont plus compliqués
il faudra avoir des assistances à
maîtrise ouvrages pour que ces chantiers
puissent être développés notamment avec
dans l'habitat collectif et les
copropriétés puisque ces chantiers
seront d'une complexité bien plus grande
que celui qu'on a connu mais je peux
vous assurer qu'on travaille
d'arrache-pied à la qualification de
cette filière
j'étais au salon Batimat il y a quelques
semaines pour voir un certain décembre
d'école et d'entreprises qui pré
professionnels un certain nombre de
jeunes notamment aux métiers du bâtiment
et en particulier ceux de la rénovation
thermique merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Madame l'air noes
oui monsieur le ministre plus le temps
passe plus l'espoir d'un sursaut de du
marché pour rénover du notre parc de
logement s'amuse pourtant on sait que
notre premier levier de transition
énergétique et la baisse des
consommations et notamment dans le
secteur du bâtiment vos dernières
mesures que vous venez d'évoquer
compenseront au mieux l'inflation et
limiteront une baisse des chiffres mais
c'est tout au final rien pour répondre à
nos objectifs nous attendons toujours
l'annonce des mesures pour massifier les
rénovations performantes et enfin agir
dans les temps impartis pour l'urgence
sociale et climatique il s'agit d'un des
échecs les plus criants de votre
politique en 2021 faute d'incitation
financière suffisante 70% des aides ont
été affectés au seul changement du
système de chauffage en plus d'un rythme
de rénovation bien trop faible les
travaux réalisés ne présentent pas assez
de bénéfices par rapport à l'effort
d'investissement des ménages en
particulier pour les plus modestes
pire ils impactent fortement leur budget
et bloque tout nouveau investissement
qui amélioraient pour de bons leur
quotidien tout en nous permettant
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone depuis
le début de cette mandature le groupe
écologiste nupes a formulé de nombreuses
propositions
6,8 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour la rénovation reste à charge zéro
pour les ménages les plus modestes et
minimes pour les revenus intermédiaires
certains de nos amendements avaient été
adoptés démocratiquement par cette
hémisphique hémicycle mais aussitôt
balayé par votre gouvernement ainsi
avez-vous prévu de changer de braquet
dans votre stratégie et d'inciter
davantage financièrement à la
réalisation de rénovation performante
plutôt que port monogest en particulier
pour les personnes aux revenus les plus
modestes je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée vous avez
raison le reste à charge ne doit pas
être un frein ou être un frein le moins
important possible pour le lancement des
travaux c'est pour ça que nous avons
décidé la mise en place d'un éco-prés à
taux zéro pour le reste a charge une
méthodologie simplifiée puisque les
documents donnés pour la demande de ma
prime rénov pourront être immédiatement
transmis sans faire d'autres demandes
aux banques qui sont partenaires de les
coprais et il est extrêmement important
pour nous notamment dans le cas des de
l'habitat collectif j'y reviens et
notamment les copropriétés que ce
travail partenarial
France rénov Lana permettent
d'accompagner les copropriétés celles
qui vont bien celles qui vont moins bien
celles qui sont dans des dispositifs de
suivi tels que les opas les plantes
sauvegardes ou autres pour que le niveau
d'aide soit le plus important possible
je l'ai annoncé il y a quelques semaines
je vais rencontrer avec le ministre
Bruno Le Maire les banquiers pour voir
comment ils vont continuer à être
présent auprès des copropriétés soit
auprès des copropriétaires soit auprès
du syndic de copropriété pour
accompagner ses projets pour que à un
moment en assemblée générale de
copropriété vous savez comment ça marche
les les chantiers ne soient pas refusés
faute de capacité à faire et puis le
niveau d'aide a été relevé il est passé
de 15000 à 25000 euros pour pouvoir
aider les copropriété le plus
efficacement possible dans leur projet
ce que je veux vous dire enfin pour
terminer c'est que aujourd'hui les aides
telles qu'elles ont existé ont concerné
80% de ménage modestes et très modestes
aujourd'hui ma prime rénov est une est
une aide qui concerne les ménages
modestes et c'est heureux et 90% de ces
aides oui vous l'avez dit on concernait
des modifications notamment de système
de chauffage et la diminution de
l'utilisation de gaz à effet de donc on
est dans une démarche qui avance qui
marche mais sur lequel on partage avec
vous la nécessité d'aller plus loin
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur tâché merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
gouverner c'est d'abord loger son peuple
souvent répété ces mots de la baie
pierre sont plus que jamais d'actualité
car aujourd'hui le mal logement c'est
aussi souvent un logement mal isolé et
parmi nos concitoyens les locataires HLM
sont une partie une population
particulièrement exposée à cette
problématique même s'il faut en
connaître que la qualité thermique du
parc HLM est légèrement supérieur à
celle du reste du parc immobilier il a
néanmoins urgence à se concentrer sur la
rénovation de nos logements sociaux rien
que dans ma circonscription à
Cergy-Pontoise c'est 8100 logements qui
sont étiquetés comme passoire
énergétique une urgence d'abord parce
que le prix Les prix de l'énergie flambe
c'est d'ailleurs sociaux bénéficient du
bouclier du bouclier tarifaire pour le
chauffage collectif au gaz ce n'est pas
le cas pour les frais concernant les
parties communes mais aussi pour les
immeubles chauffés à l'électricité ces
charges sont ensuite répercutées sur les
locataires dans des sur les locataires
dans des immeubles qui pour beaucoup
sont de véritables passoires une urgence
aussi car les bailleurs depuis le
janvier ne peuvent plus louer les
logements classés G qui consomment plus
de 450 kWh d'énergie finale ce qui est
évidemment très bien mais implique que
51 000 logements sociaux vont risque
d'être exclus du parc si les rénovations
ne sont pas faites d'ici à 2034 c'est
près d'un virgule deux millions de
logements que les bailleurs sociaux
auront rénové pour pour une facture qui
dépassera les 40 milliards d'euros et je
rappelle qu'effectivement pendant le
projet de loi de finance le gouvernement
n'a pas retenu un amendement que nous
avions fait adopter grâce à ma collègue
evasas qui vous l'a rappelé et qui à
l'ouest 6,8 milliards d'euros de plus
pour la rénovation thermique si rien
n'est fait monsieur le ministre nous
allons vers une catastrophe pouvons-nous
nous permettre de pousser les gens vers
la rue alors que plus de 300000
personnes comme vous le savez déjà non
toujours pas de toi une urgence enfin
car la production annuelle de logements
sociaux s'est effondré alors qu'elle
s'établissait à 123000 logements en 2016
elle se situe autour de 95 000 logements
chaque année depuis la mise en place de
la RLS la production s'effondre et le
manque de rénovation pourrait conduire à
réduire le nombre de logements
disponibles voilà donc chers collègues
ma question qui est très simple quand le
gouvernement va-t-il investir de manière
massive dans le logement social et sa
rénovation
d'éviter la catastrophe vers laquelle
nous nous dirigeons je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Tachet monsieur le
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Aurélien taché d'abord une information
qui malheureusement vous a échappé
aujourd'hui tous les boucliers sont en
œuvre un décret du 31 décembre complète
les boucliers et il y a bien un bouclier
sur le chauffage collectif électrique et
et un bouclier sur les parties communes
et aujourd'hui l'ensemble des cas sont
couverts chauffage individuel gaz
électrique chauffage collectif gaz
chauffage électrique
collectif et les parties communes et je
m'en réjouis et même pour les les
bailleurs sociaux qui auraient pris des
abonnements trop chers et bien il y a
une majoration du bouclier pour que ça
ne soit pas les locataires qui qui le
payent ensuite bien évidemment je
partage tous la nécessité d'avoir la
même qualité de rénovation thermique de
l'habitat social comme sur l'habitat
privé
j'ai confiance dans les bailleurs
sociaux et dans leur volonté de faire
ils ont déjà fait mais pas suffisamment
vous l'avez dit environ 400 000
logements sociaux sont classés F et G et
la la rénovation de ces logements n'a
pas été assez vite ces dernières années
alors de manière extrêmement différente
d'ailleurs social à l'autre et certains
groupes plus puissants ont pu mettre en
place un certain nombre de projets cette
partie là est au coeur de notre
réflexion avec l'ensemble des bailleurs
sociaux dans le cadre du du pacte de
confiance que nous sommes en train
d'écrire avec eux nous avons inscrit
dans le snap 2023 200 millions d'euros
pour compléter les efforts qui avaient
déjà été lancés dans le cadre du plan de
relance pour accompagner seulement la
partie rénovation thermique en plus des
300 millions d'euros qui ont fait
l'objet de discussion avec Action
Logement donc cette volonté de
rénovation du parc est présent et puis
vous le savez j'ai été président de la
rue au cœur des programmes de rénovation
urbaine la question de la rénovation
thermique du parc est extrêmement
présente et enfin nous travaillons sur
dispositif qu'on appelle à ce stade
seconde vie qui permet d'avoir des
rénovations extrêmement puissantes du
parc social dans lequel on pourrait
recommencer une histoire nouvelle du
logement social et donc permettre à ses
logements rénovés de manière massive de
recommencer leur vie de logements social
avec des aides telles qu'elles existent
à la création du logement social merci
nous passons au groupe gauche-démocrate
et républicaine la parole est à Monsieur
vulx
le ministre la rénovation du parc
immobilier notamment pour les logements
les plus énergiveux et évidemment une
priorité la loi climère résilience doute
21 va en quelque sorte faire sortir du
marché locatif privé les logements les
plus mal classés dès ce début d'année on
parle de quelques 400 000 logements
selon les estimations qui ne vont plus
être autorisées à la location à terme on
parle de 1 million 600000 logements
c'est un premier pas pour bannir les
passoires thermiques et s'attaquer à la
location de logements indécent la
démarche ne serait cependant être
suffisante si elle se solde par un
retrait à court et moyen terme d'un
patrimoine locatif dans une période où
l'accès au logement pour nos concitoyens
est de plus en plus problématique ainsi
donc le coût de la rénovation de ses
logements coût d'isolation et travaux
induits est un indicateur clé
pour un logement passoire thermique il
est estimé entre 600 et 800 euros le
mètre carré et en moyenne à 38.000 euros
l'unité d'habitat monsieur le ministre
estimez-vous contrairement à beaucoup
d'observateurs que le coût global de la
remise sur le marché de ces logements
mis aux normes
est apprécié à hauteur de 16 milliards
d'euros et réaliste et à défaut quelle
disposition de soutien supplémentaire le
gouvernement va-t-il prendre pour éviter
la contraction de l'offre locative et
pour les notamment les petits
propriétaires bailleurs nous considérons
que l'Agence nationale de l'amélioration
de l'habitat doit accroître son rôle de
soutien et de pilote de cette politique
en portant d'ailleurs parallèlement
plus fortement le conventionnement des
logements privés rénovés aux fins de
prévenir tout inflation du coup des
logements
que le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
plusieurs sujets d'abord je pense qu'on
peut partager ensemble l'absolu
nécessité
d'exclure les passoires thermiques les
taudis thermiques de l'offre de location
puisque les gens qui habitent dedans des
familles que l'on connaît vous et moi
dans nos villes sont des victimes sont
des victimes pas toujours de marchands
de sommeil mais au moins de
propriétaires indélicats qui encaissent
des loyers et donc à ce titre ont des
obligations vous le savez les bailleurs
les propriétaires bailleurs sont
éligibles à toutes les aides et c'est
une évolution toutes les aides y compris
le déficit foncier qui leur permet de
déduire de leurs impôts les travaux qui
qu'ils ont pu faire donc et puis
il y a évidemment un risque mais vous le
savez aussi ce qui est interdit c'est la
remise en location la reprise de bail
personne ne va se retrouver dehors ça
n'aurait ça n'a aucun sens mais en même
temps ces propriétaires qui encaissent
les loyers ont des obligations et je ne
souhaite pas qu'on les libère de ces
autorisations et même je souhaite
peut-être qu'on y reviendra qu'on soit
attentif qu'il y ait pas un vaste
communicant qui d'un seul coup ferait
que un logement proche du taux dit
thermique se retrouve sur un site
internet comme un meublé touristique
avec des jolies nœuds aux fenêtres et
pourraient et certains pourraient
profiter d'un basculement ou d'une
interdiction de remise dans Location
pour basculer dans le meublé touristique
ou dans le ou dans le meuble et donc
nous serons très attentifs parce que il
n'y ait pas une fuite des logements
parce que on est tous d'accord pour dire
qu'on a besoin de plus de logements pour
loger nos habitants je pense qu'il faut
continuer à mettre la pression sur ceux
qui sont propriétaires et qui ont des
obligations en tant que propriétaire ce
qu'ils encaissent souvent des loyers
depuis de nombreuses années et je l'ai
dit et je le redis tous les
propriétaires y compris les
propriétaires bailleurs sont éligibles à
ces aides ils peuvent bénéficier de
l'accompagnateur Renov de ma prime Ré et
donc il faut pas qu'ils attendent les
dates butoir pour lancer les travaux
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Monet
nous passons au groupe démocrate modem
indépendant la parole est à Madame Gatel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre depuis le 1er janvier 2023 et
jusqu'en 2028 la location des parts
soirs thermiques passées F et G sera
progressivement interdite nous n'avons
que trop tardé à agir sur la rénovation
du parc de logement et je salue
l'ambition du gouvernement sur cette
question essentielle le secteur
résidentiel représentant la deuxième
source de pollution de l'air à Paris
compte tenu de la spécificité et de
l'ancienneté du bâti les logements F et
G représentent 31% des résidences
principales et même les deux tiers du
parc locatif privé des chiffres bien
supérieurs au reste de la France ce qui
rend d'autant plus
urgent d'agir en faveur de la rénovation
thermique
mais certains bailleurs envisagent
d'orger déjà de proposer leurs biens en
tant que location saisonnière les
meublés n'étant pas à ce stade concernés
par les dispositions de la loi climat et
résilience d'où le risque d'une baisse
du nombre de biens disponibles à la
location alors même que 1,3 millions de
personnes sont mal logées en
Île-de-France et la crainte d'amoindrir
l'effet de la loi climat sur la qualité
thermique du bâti et donc sur le niveau
des missions des gaz à effet de serre
monsieur le ministre en octobre dernier
et vous l'avez fait à l'instant vous
avez fait part de votre détermination à
agir sur le sujet en indiquant que les
mêmes règles devaient s'appliquer aux
meublés et aux non meublés
même la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés madame la députée je vais
essayer de ne pas être trop redondant
dans dans mes réponses plusieurs sujets
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit l'exigence
d'un niveau de performance énergétique
minimale ne concerne pour l'instant que
le logement principal et il y a un
risque de déport vers des meublés et des
meublés touristiques et ça n'aurait
aucun sens que c'est pas soit thermique
d'un seul coup bascule d'un statut à un
autre pour s'éviter les travaux à ce
stade il est difficile d'évaluer même si
vous l'avez un peu fait le nombre de
logements concernés et d'abord d'évaluer
les propriétaires qui trouveraient cette
voix de d'échappement néanmoins il faut
trouver le volet le volet législatif
nous permettant d'intervenir et
d'empêcher ça c'est pas complètement
simple vous le savez les règles de la
propriété de la propriété privée sont
assez
sévèrement encadré et vous avez aussi
évoquer la manière dont on pouvait faire
évoluer les règles de la copropriété la
majorité simple la majorité qualifiée
tout ce qui fait que une décision sera
prise ou pas en assemblée générale donc
c'est des sujets sur lesquels je vais
pas vous donner de réponse très précise
aujourd'hui d'abord qui dépasse le champ
de mon propre ministère mais et aussi
celui du garde des sceaux puisque c'est
plutôt chez lui que mais c'est des
chantiers que nous avons déjà mis en
oeuvre parce que si on veut réussir la
rénovation thermique de l'habitat
collectif et en particulier des
copropriétés vous avez vu aussi le drame
de Vaulx-en-Velin que que l'on a pu
connaître malheureusement il y a
quelques semaines et bien il est
important de se doter de tous les outils
et il manque encore un certain nombre
d'outils je crois pour rénover plus vite
une copropriété que ça soit d'un point
de vue énergétique que sur les autres
points de vue donc c'est des chantiers
sur lesquels on est présent et on
travaille et pour le basculement sur le
meublé touristique on cherche le le bon
volet législatif et je ne doute pas
qu'on pourra compter sur l'ensemble ou
une grande partie des députés de ces
différents bancs pour nous accompagner
sur ce sujet merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Morel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le secteur du
bâtiment représente 20 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre française
l'essentiel est en lié au chauffage le
développement d'une véritable politique
publique de rénovation énergétique des
logements depuis 5 ans répond ainsi à de
multiples enjeux lutte contre le
changement climatique soutient au
pouvoir d'achat et amélioration de la
qualité de vie des Français diminution
de notre dépendance énergétique liée à
nos approvisionnements notamment en cas
de hausse des prix de l'énergie il faut
le souligner de nombreux dispositifs de
soutien en ménage ont été mis en place
par le gouvernement et la majorité tel
que ma prime rénove les co-prés à taux
zéro la prime coup de pouce économie
d'énergie etc toutefois monsieur le
ministre je suis régulièrement
interpellé par des habitants de demeure
traditionnelles alsaciennes qui si elles
sont anciennes et magnifiques abritant
parfois quelques nids de cigognes
peuvent parfois être de véritables
passoir thermique souhaitant réaliser
des travaux d'isolation les habitants
sont confrontés à deux problèmes majeurs
premièrement accéder aux aides alloués
via ma prime rénov peut se révéler être
en véritable casse-tête administrative
deuxièmement les projets de rénovation
thermique et autres projets de
transition énergétique concernant des
bâtiments situés en zone classée sont
soumis à des formalités et des avis
préalables obligatoires notamment l'avis
de l'Architecte des Bâtiments de France
or ces projets font presque
systématiquement l'objet d'un avis de
principe défavorable de l'architecte des
bâtiments de France quelle solution
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
peut-il apporter à ses problématiques
qui sont des freins évidents à la
massification de la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments empêchant de ce fait les
particuliers de bonne volonté
d'effectuer les travaux nécessaires je
vous remercie de vos éclairages
merci Madame Morel monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée concernant les difficultés
administratives pour bénéficier des
aides ma prime rénove elles existent et
nous n'ayons pas et nous travaillons
avec la nappe pour améliorer la fluidité
et la capacité à accéder à ses aides et
c'est normal c'est d'ailleurs le nom le
rôle des conseillers France rénov et des
accompagnateurs rénov et c'est vraiment
un objectif constant que l'on partage
avec Lana et sur lequel on travaille
d'arrache-pied
le guichet unique France Renov est déjà
une amélioration la présence d'un
dispositif d'accompagnement avec mon
incapable ordinateur renf qui a été
lancé il y a quelques jours va permettre
je crois de simplifier les démarches
pour les ménages puisqu'ils y trouveront
plus facilement conseil et aide ensuite
le gouvernement continuera à travailler
sur la simplification en regardant par
exemple comment rapprocher les critères
d'éligibilité entre les différentes
aides à de rénovation énergétique
aujourd'hui ça reste encore un peu
compliqué ma prime rénov laisser deux
heures et c'est aussi le rôle de
l'accompagnateur Renov d'être efficace
dans les informations et de faire que
toutes les aides soient mobilisées le
plus rapidement possible soit
directement à l'entreprise soit au
particulier s'agissant de la qualité
patrimoniale que vous évoquez environ
30% des logements en France sont
concernés par des mesures patrimoniales
ABS et l'ancien maire que je suis et
particulièrement concerné puisque une
partie du territoire de Clichy et dans
ce patrimoine ABS et ça peut
effectivement poser des problèmes le
gouvernement a soutenu la proposition du
député Bastien Marchive sur la prise en
compte par les ABS des objectifs de
transition énergétique et en 2022 un
groupe de travail a été mis en place en
lien avec le ministère de la Culture sur
cette question et des représentants des
ABS ce groupe de travail a pour objet de
recenser les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer les propriétaires de
logements que ce soit de l'habitat
individuel ou de l'habitat collectif
bien évidemment une isolation par
l'extérieur et parfois à regarder avec
étonnement par les ABS mais pour ce qui
est de l'habitat alsacien je ne suis pas
certain que l'isolation par l'extérieur
soit la bonne réponse et donc c'est tout
ça qu'il faut travailler ensemble merci
monsieur le ministre nous passons au
groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Monsieur Adam merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lancez le 1er janvier 2020 le dispositif
m'a prime rénov rencontre un succès
incontestable avec près de 800 000
demandes l'année dernière c'est un
maillon essentiel pour parvenir à nos
objectifs de rénovation énergétique des
logements toutefois comme je l'imagine
nombre de parlementaires et vous même
monsieur le ministre je suis
régulièrement saisi sur les besoins
d'amélioration du dispositif en effet
force est de constater que le nombre de
rénovations globale effectué à travers
ce dispositif étant de ça les attentes
et des besoins c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire selon moi de le faire évoluer
sur quatre axes premièrement les aides
pour la rénovation énergétique des
logements sont encore trop complexes
avec d'un côté ma primaire de l'autre
laisser deux œufs auquel peuvent venir
s'ajouter des aides locales je propose
donc que pour une rénovation globale
le montant des C2E souhaite intégrer
directement dans le montant de m'imprime
rénov et que ce soit Lana qui gère la
relation avec les émetteurs des C2E
deuxième axe urgent d'amélioration du
dispositif le DPE le diagnostic de
performance énergétique sur le montant
estimé des travaux il peut en effet
indiquer un montant de travaux de 30000
€ pour faire une rénovation alors qu'il
faudra au final plus double voire du
triple pour faire cette dernière cette
situation peut mettre en difficulté des
citoyens qui basent leurs décisions
d'achat d'un bien sur ce qui est indiqué
par le DPE 3e axe le montant des aides
en cas de rénovation globale il n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu après
déduction de l'imprimerie neuve des C2E
et des aides de Lana le reste à charge
est rénovations globale est encore
prohibitif c'est d'autant plus vrai pour
les ménages les plus modestes qui ne
peuvent bien souvent pas se lancer dans
une rénovation globale alors que ce doit
être notre public prioritaire je salue
la décision du gouvernement fin décembre
d'augmenter le montant de la prime pour
2023 mais nous devons aller encore plus
loin pour tous les ménages il faut
mettre en oeuvre ce que le rapport
Sichel préconisé à savoir pour les
ménages modestes un reste à charge
limité à 5% du montant des travaux et
jusqu'à 40% maximum pour les plus aisés
enfin quatrième axe l'État doit être
beaucoup plus rapide dans le versement
des adoménagers il faut construire une
logique d'avance pour que les ménages
n'aient qu'à payer le reste à charge
sans devoir avancer le montant des aides
de l'État sur ces quatre pistes de
l'amélioration ou de ma prime rénove je
souhaiterais donc monsieur ministre
savoir quelle solution vous envisagez
pour améliorer améliorer le dispositifs
afin que la France accélère encore la
rénovation de notre parc de logement je
vous remercie merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés je partage
avec vous le constat d'une certaine
complexité des aides à la rénovation en
particulier concernant le cumul des
aides entre elles les efforts de
simplification conduisent ces dernières
années doivent être approfondies et nous
y travaillons activement je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure notamment avec Lana
toutefois à ce stade il n'est pas
possible de fusionner les aides ma prime
rénov qui constituent une aide publique
et les aides sous forme de C2E issus de
contributions obligatoires des
fournisseurs d'énergie comme vous le
savez en revanche nous avons des marges
de manœuvre apportant de progrès pour
mieux les articuler rapprocher les
critères d'éligibilité faciliter leur
compréhension et mobilisation par les
ménages ce qui est d'ailleurs le rôle
des accompagnateurs rénovs tel qu'ils
seront mis en place je partage avec vous
l'importance d'un accompagnement
généralisé que vous mentionnez et ça
sera le sens du service public France
rénov avec son extension de l'action dès
le 1er avec les accompagnateurs rénov
sur le versement des aides les
demandeurs peuvent et doit connaître
doivent connaître avant la réalisation
des travaux le montant de la prime qui
leur sera versée ils ont besoin d'être
éclairés de plus en tout cas c'est
l'objectif qui est notre les aide
doivent être faire c dans quelques
semaines dans des délais beaucoup plus
courts et aujourd'hui on est environ à
15 à 20 jours mais parfois il y a encore
des difficultés mais on était à
plusieurs mois voire dizaines de mois il
y a encore quelques semaines avec le
crédit d'impôt notamment à la transition
énergétique enfin sur l'avance de
trésorerie Lana accord des avances sur
demande des ménages très modestes
bénéficiaires de ma prime manov pouvant
atteindre jusqu'à 70% du montant des
travaux et puis comme je l'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure il y aura il y a des
produits bancaires que nous mettons en
place sur le reste à charge dont l'éco
PTZ dont nous avons simplifié
l'instruction avec une demande unique
faite à l'Agence France Renov qui pourra
être transmis ensuite à l'AG carte
bancaire et on travaille à ce que plus
de banques acceptent ce dispositif de
transmission des documents merci
la parole est à Monsieur Amiel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ma prime rénov a été un grand
succès de ces dernières années mais pour
autant elle n'épuise pas la question du
soutien à la demande particulièrement et
ça a été mentionné auparavant en matière
de rénovation globale l'État ne pourra
faire pas tout subventionner mais les
ménages ne pourront pas tout avancer et
il nous faut donc des solutions
innovantes deux enjeux en particulier me
paraissent cruciaux le premier c'est le
savoir comment l'on pourrait rendre plus
transparent le coût des travaux au
moment de l'acquisition d'un logement
pour qu'il puisse être pris en compte
dans la négociation entre l'acheteur et
le vendeur et le modèle de financement
faudrait-il d'ailleurs le cas échéant
dans les copropriétés bloquer une
certaine somme au moment de l'achat pour
permettre le financement ultérieur des
travaux dans l'immeuble le deuxième
enjeu central c'est évidemment l'avance
de frais les difficultés trésories des
ménages sont un frein important entre
les sommes à débourser immédiatement
pour les travaux et des gains de
l'efficacité énergétique qui sont eux
très étalées dans le temps sur quelle
piste travaillez-vous monsieur le
ministre pour généraliser les avances de
fonds remboursables uniquement quand les
économies d'énergie se matérialisent
cela avec les opérateurs ensemblaient
proposés par France stratégie qui serait
maître d'oeuvre et financeur des travaux
et se rémunérer ensuite directement sur
les factures d'énergie mais cela peut
aussi passer par des dispositifs de
prêts aux propriétaires remboursables
uniquement principal comme intérêt au
moment d'une vente ou d'une succession
du bien c'est la très bonne idée du prêt
avance rénovation qui commence à se
déployer cette année mais dans les
plafonds de ressources sont aujourd'hui
très bas ne pourrait-on pas augmenter
ses plafonds de ressources pour rendre
ce prêt avancer rénovation accessible au
plus grand nombre
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
je partage avec vous l'importance
d'informer de façon précise l'acquéreur
d'un logement sur les coûts associés à
sa rénovation thermique grâce à la loi
climat résilience la réalisation d'un
otite énergétique va devenir obligatoire
à partir du 1er avril 2023 pour la vente
des logements en copropriété classé F et
en monopropriété pardon classé F et G
cette dite devra être remis à
l'acquéreur dès la première visite du
logement pour les copropriétés la loi
climat et résilience a rendu obligatoire
l'élaboration d'un plan pluriannuel des
travaux un PPT pour toutes les
copropriétés au plus tard d'ici l'année
2025 après le plan le vote de ce plan
par l'assemblée générale de la
copropriété le syndicat des
copropriétaires devra provisionner les
sommes nécessaires au financement des
actions de ce PPT dans le cadre d'un
faux d'un fond travaux alimenté par
chaque copropriétaire un fond travaux
spécifique puisque vous connaissez la
question des copropriétés concernant le
second sujet de votre question Lana
accordent et je viens d'en parler sur
demande des ménages très modestes
bénéficiaires de ma prime rénov une
avance pouvant atteindre jusqu'à 70% du
montant des travaux enfin des produits
bancaires sont également proposés pour
financer le reste à charge des médailles
le plus modeste tels que l'Echo PTZ dont
une partie a été couplée à ma prime
manœuvre j'en ai déjà parlé enfin c'est
le cas également et vous venez d'en
parler du prêt avance rénovation le par
dont le remboursement n'intervient que
lors de la lors de la mutation du bien
et qui mérite d'être davantage connu de
tous en particulier des ménages
âgés et modestes avec des difficultés
d'accès auprès classique cette question
du financement du reste à charge et du
prêt financement des aides constituent
une de nos priorités sur lesquelles nous
continuons à travailler avec l'ensemble
des acteurs et en particulier Lana je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Armand
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans le
contexte actuel et face à l'urgence de
la transition énergétique et écologique
la rénovation énergétique est à la fois
une nécessité et une priorité dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 j'ai rendu un avis sur
le programme comprenant les crédits
dédiés à la rénovation énergétique des
logements et les dizaines d'auditions
d'acteurs et d'experts du secteur que
nous avons conduites mène à un constat
clair les dernières années ont permis de
faire des progrès inédits mais nous
sommes encore loin du compte ma prime
rénove qui élève la plus sollicité et la
plus connue de nos compatriotes
présentent un bilan incontestablement
positif près de 1 million et demi de
dossiers en ont bénéficié depuis sa mise
en place et en 2022 ce sont 83% des
montants de primes engagés qui
reviennent au ménage modestes et très
modestes et en 2023 on peut s'en
féliciter le gouvernement accentue son
effort avec 500 millions d'euros de plus
pour l'enveloppe dédiés à ma prime rénov
et la mise en place d'un accompagnement
renforcé et individualisé des 5 euros de
travaux à partir du 1er janvier ce
dernier aspect monsieur le ministre
celui de l'accompagnement est
indispensable parce que la rénovation
geste par geste est encore la norme
selon la Cour des comptes elle
représente environ 86% des chantiers
financés par ma prime rénove en 2021 il
est donc primordial que ces rénovations
soient effectuer selon une approche
globale avec des travaux pensés par
étape et réalisés en cohérence pour cela
nous devons mieux articuler l'ensemble
des mesures et des aides existantes pour
les rénovations globales elles doivent
apparaître nettement plus incitatives
que la rénovation geste par geste un
seul exemple le cumul de ma prime rénov
est déprime ces deux œufs pour des
travaux effectués séparément reste plus
avantageux que les aides délivrées pour
un projet global et performant et on
connaît aussi le coût et le temps
nécessaire pour effectuer une rénovation
globale ainsi je vous demande monsieur
le ministre quelle mesure le
gouvernement compte mettre en place pour
aller plus loin encore dans ces
programmes d'incitation et pour aider
les particuliers mais aussi les
entreprises et les collectivités à
baisser leur reste à charge pour
procéder à des progression globale bien
plus efficace à la fois en termes
économique et énergétique je vous
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député je ne reviens
pas sur les constats que nous partageons
ceux des progrès importants que la
politique publique de la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments a connu au cours
du quinquennat précédent mais aussi
celui du chemin qui nous reste à
parcourir pour aller vers plus de
rénovations performante voire globale
une rénovation performante restera
toujours une entreprise complexe pour
massifier ces rénovations profondes je
suis convaincu qu'il nous faut proposer
aux usagers un parcours aussi clair et
lisible que possible ce qui implique
d'en améliorer et d'en simplifier encore
chacune des étapes il faut réussir
l'entrée dans le parcours c'est le rôle
du service public France Renov dans la
montée en charge se poursuit contenu de
la complexité de ces travaux les ménages
doivent pouvoir s'appuyer sur un tiers
tout au long de leur projet c'est la
raison d'être des accompagnateurs rénovs
il est essentiel que les aides
accessibles soient lisibles et plus
incitatif comme vous l'avez rappelé
que pour des rénovations partielles même
si il faut pas jeter comme on dit le
bébé avec l'eau du bain et que cette
somme des rénovations partielles a quand
même eu un effet très important c'est le
cap de que nous nous donnons en 2023
avec le relèvement des plafonds de ma
prime rénov sérénité de ma prime rénov
copropriété et du forfait rénovation
globale en plus des aides incitatives
les solutions de financement du reste à
charge doivent être facilement
accessibles pour qu'il ne constituent
pas un frein à l'engagement comme nous
l'avons déjà rappelé plusieurs fois cet
après-midi enfin j'évoquerai
l'importance que les ménages et accès à
des entreprises compétentes en matière
de rénovation performante dans
lesquelles ils ont toutes confiance
cette question du parcours est au moins
aussi centrale dans l'habitat collectif
que dans l'habitat individuel est
constituent l'une de mes priorités je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur le roi
merci madame la Présidente et
permettez-moi pour commencer de vous
souhaiter une très bonne année de 2023
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de nos collègues
ici réunis et à vous monsieur le
ministre aime également monsieur le
ministre moi ce que je trouve
remarquable dans le débat aujourd'hui
c'est que dans une certaine manière pour
les politiques publiques qu'on a
l'habitude de discuter c'est
relativement consensuel la réalité c'est
que cette politique de rénovation
thermique c'est la politique la plus
évidente en matière de changement
climatique mais aussi en matière de
souveraineté mais aussi en matière de
création d'emplois c'est une évidence
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
mais qu'il faut accélérer beaucoup pour
arriver à remplir nos ambitions
climatiques alors dans les dernières
années il y a eu la loi climat et
résilience on en a parlé a eu ma prime
rénov grand succès il y a l'augmentation
des moyens de la NH il y a France
relance qui a essayé de structurer la
fille il y a eu beaucoup de progrès mais
je vais vous faire une confidence
monsieur le ministre il y a plus de 15
ans dans une autre vie et je parlais où
j'ai étudié la première directive pour
l'efficacité énergétique à niveau
européen et on se posait déjà les
questions qu'on se pose aujourd'hui sur
comment massifier
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments si
j'avais encore des cheveux je me les
arracherai et du coup monsieur le
ministre au fond j'ai deux questions la
première c'est qu'en France on a une
particularité c'est qu'on a une filière
de la rénovation thermique qui n'est pas
parfaitement structurée en Allemagne il
y a des ETI qui vous font tout de
rénovation de bout en bout et il y en a
sur tout le territoire de façon
extrêmement efficace comment est-ce que
le gouvernement comment est-ce qu'on
aide la filière à se structurer pour
être en mesure d'industrialiser
d'industrialiser la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments et puis la deuxième
monsieur le ministre c'est au fond une
question peut-être un peu simpliste mais
c'est du point de vue du ménage comment
est-ce qu'on fait en sorte qu'un ménage
que des propriétaires que chaque ménage
que chaque propriétaire en France se
voit confronter à une offre de
rénovation thermique qui les démarches
comment est-ce qu'on crée le montage
financier comment est-ce qu'on s'assure
que dans toute notre société chaque
propriétaire soit mis aujourd'hui ou
dans les années qui suivent devant cette
proposition financière pratique concrète
immédiate rapide voilà mais deux
questions monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
alroyd le logement
c'est 30% de nos consommations d'énergie
mais je suis convaincu que le logement
peut être aussi l'avant-garde éclairé de
la transition écologique et c'est ce que
nous évoquons depuis le début de cet
après-midi l'avant-garde éclairée de la
transition écologique pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique pour
garantir notre indépendance énergétique
pour protéger les plus modestes de la
précarité énergétique depuis 2017 grâce
à l'engagement des députés notamment de
la majorité nous avons augmenté le
rythme de la rénovation thermique avec
700 000 rénovations de logements par an
même un peu plus puisque nous avons
atteint le chiffre de 1,5 millions de
rénovation et c'est inédit le bilan est
bon mais maintenant il faut aller plus
vite plus loin et plus fort et c'est ce
que nous faisons avec la montée en
puissance de France rénov avec le
déploiement progressif des
accompagnateurs de même que la
mobilisation des financeurs privés et de
la simplification des dispositifs de
financement du reste à charge s'agit
sans de la structuration de la filière
industrielle que vous avez évoquée elle
fait partie des objectifs de la
planification écologique à travers un
plan d'action en matière de formation
d'attractivité de ces métiers ça a été
évoqué au début de cet après-midi de
qualité et d'animation de l'offre des
appels à projets spécifiques sont déjà
prévus dans le cadre de France 2030
permettez-moi de dire un mot aussi de la
rénovation des bâtiments publics puisque
le c'est un enjeu d'exemplarité et le
président de la République a fixé une
ambition très claire notamment en cas de
la rénovation des écoles mais aussi des
gymnases et l'ancien président de la rue
était très que je suis était très
attaché à la question du bâtiment du
bâti scolaire et je connais votre
mobilisation monsieur le député ainsi
que celle de l'engagement de la Caisse
des Dépôts que vous que vous présidez
maintenant pour cette participation à la
rénovation des équipements publics qui
feront bien sûr un effort très important
sur la limitation des gaz à effet de
serre merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Marchive
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre l'année 2022 et désormais
derrière nous et elle nous a durement
rappeler l'impératif de rénovation
énergétique impératif environnemental
puisque le logement représente 20% de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
impératif économique puisque le prix
d'électricité a énormément pesé sur le
budget des Français imprime rénov qui a
été longuement évoquée dans ses débats
est un des piliers de notre action en la
matière il a ainsi permis d'augmenter et
de multiplier par 10 le nombre de
d'actes de rénovation à défaut de
rénovation globale puisque c'est bien là
l'objectif que nous devons nous fixer et
en la matière le potentiel d'économie
d'énergie est assez conséquent la
rénovation globale devant devenir la
norme
elle doit en France l'être aussi dans
les centres villes et les centres-bours
et c'est là où la difficulté perdure en
particulier dans les périmètres protégés
nous adoptions vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le ministre il y a un mois et
par un large consensus que je salue un
amendement qui est obligé les ABS à
prendre en compte des objectifs de
rénovation énergétique et de
développement des énergies renouvelables
c'est une réelle avancée puisque en
permettant le maintien au niveau de
protection du patrimoine grâce à
l'expertise deux architectes des
bâtiments de France
nous concilions également cela avec les
enjeux de transition environnementale et
les objectifs de développement des
énergies renouvelables alors les
attentes sont nombreuses en la matière
il s'agit de particulier d'entreprises
ou de collectivités et si 2022 aura été
l'année de la consécration de cette
nouveauté 2023 doit être celle de sa
mise en œuvre et c'est à ce propos
monsieur le ministre que je souhaite
vous interroger puisque plusieurs
questions peuvent se poser notamment
celles de la formation des architectes
des bâtiments de France ou encore l'idée
d'une nomenclature qui viendrait
objectiver la manière dont ils peuvent
prendre leur décision à défaut la
discrétionarité restera bien le principe
et je me permets donc monsieur le
ministre de vous demander comment le
gouvernement compte décliner ces
différents objets et ces différentes
orientations que nous nous sommes
maintenant fixés et en particulier dans
quel calendrier je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le
la présidente monsieur madame mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
députés archives la conciliation de la
protection de notre patrimoine bâti et
la transition et de la transition
environnementale dans ce secteur est un
sujet important
environ 30% des logements des Français
sont concernés directement ou
directement par des mesures de
protection patrimoniale c'est un enjeu
clé pour massifier les rénovations
énergétiques performantes à la fois dans
l'habitat collectif mais aussi dans
l'habitat individuel le gouvernement a
soutenu votre proposition dans le cadre
des débats sur les énergies
renouvelables pour que ce soit prise en
compte par les ABS des objectifs de
transition énergétique notre soutien est
le même pour accélérer la rénovation
énergétique à la recherche du juste
équilibre entre des objectifs légitimes
de préservation ou d'amélioration de la
qualité de nos bâtiments en 2022 nous
avons donc mis en place un groupe de
travail dédié en lien avec le ministère
de la Culture et en impliquant des
représentants des ABS
l'objectif est de recenser les points de
friction entre protection patrimoniale
et rénovation performante de proposer
des pistes d'amélioration à travers la
mise en place d'outils le renforcement
de la sensibilisation et de la
l'information des acteurs soyez assurés
de la volonté du gouvernement a
faciliter l'accès des ABS à la
connaissance technique en matière de
rénovation performante grâce à une
banque de ressources documentaire plus
riche et plus facile d'accès et grâce à
la mise en place de formation adaptée
ces actions sont en cours de
développement et je continuerai monsieur
le député de vous tenir informé de leur
diplôme je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre
nous passons au groupe rassemblement
national la parole est à Monsieur Tivoli
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
rénovation énergétique des logements
répond à un triple en jeu lutter contre
le changement climatique soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat et améliorer la qualité
de vie des Français d'abord le constat
quand on résultat de ma préférée neuve
était différent 2,8 milliards d'euros
par an en servi à la rénovation de
700000 logements sur ces 700 000
logements seulement 60 000 on fait
l'objet d'une rénovation globale ce qui
signifie que pour 640 000 logements il
ne s'agit que de saupoudrage et donc
d'une très mauvaise utilisation de
l'argent public les rénovations aidés
ont provoqué pour la plupart un geste
technique isolé et non une rénovation
globale comme je le disais à l'instant
la plus efficace sur la réduction des
consommations de gaz à effet de serre et
sur la réduction des factures
d'électricité et de gaz pour les
français si quid du contrôle des
entreprises qui seront payées au travers
des ces subventions à ce jour les
entreprises dans le domaine de la
rénovation fleuriste et si certaines ont
démontré leur sérieux d'autres captent
les aides de l'étang donnant des
prestations au mieux partielles au pire
inexistante donc vous le disiez votre
objectif est de massifier la rénovation
d'ici 2050 avec quel main d'oeuvre
qu'est-ce qui est prévu au niveau de
l'apprentissage pour pallier le manque
de compétences et de main d'oeuvre et
par ailleurs vous parliez d'un écho prêt
à 0% pour les ménages avec les revenus
les plus faibles à l'heure actuelle les
petits propriétaires galèrent à se
nourrir d'ici 2025 les logements de
classe G seront interdits à la location
idem pour les logements de classe F à
compter de 2028 ne pensez-vous pas
qu'ajouter un emprunt à ces ménages dans
leur imposant la rénovation de leur
logement ne soit pas un coup
supplémentaire pour les achever je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les les députés monsieur le
député
ma prime rénove telle qu'elle existe je
tiens à le redire est un succès 1,5
millions de chantiers ont eu lieu
l'équivalent d'économies d'énergie de la
ville de Lyon c'est plus de 750 000
chantiers par an oui pour un certain
nombre de cas il s'agit de monogestes
mais de monogestes qui ont produit leurs
effets d'abord parce que c'est c'est
Z ont été attribués à déménages modestes
80% de ces aides ont été attribuées à
des ménages modestes 90% de ces aides
ont permis de changer de système de
chauffage notamment des équipements au
fioul ou des équipements au gaz et donc
les effets de ces gestes ont largement
réduit les émissions à des gaz à effet
de serre mais oui vous avez raison il
faut aller plus loin il faut aller plus
loin dans la rénovation
performante puis dans la rénovation
globale c'est les aides c'est les
améliorations qui sont en place avec la
mise en place des accompagnateurs rénov
pour que chaque projet soit accompagné
avec et éclairé par les accompagnateurs
rénov qu'on puisse connaître en amont et
le plus en amont possible les aides
auxquelles on a droit et choisir les
artisans avec les qualifications RGE
permettant de lancer ses chantiers le la
prime ma prime rénov telle qu'elle est
mise en place va nous permettre
accompagner en particulier dans les
années qui viennent l'habitat collectif
et la rénovation dans l'habitat
collectif et en particulier dans les
copropriétés quelle que soit leur état
qu'elle soit en bonne santé financière
copropriété fragile ou copropriété très
fragile et c'est le sens des chantiers
que nous menons actuellement avec la
nappe merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame grand merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
mettons-nous d'accord massifié c'est
rationalisé autrement dit pour massifier
la rénovation thermique il ne suffit pas
simplement de financer un grand nombre
de dossiers mais il faut financer un an
un grand nombre de dossiers de qualité
et sur ce point ma prime rénove pour
nous passe complètement à côté d'après
l'Agence nationale de l'habitat sur les
plus de 300000 dossiers ma prime
revenove financé au premier trimestre
2022 seul 19% des dossiers sont multi
gestes pour une moyenne d'un virgule
deux gestes seulement autrement dit
l'ont finance beaucoup de dossiers qui
ne rénove pas grand chose par ailleurs
la nature des gestes réalisés laisse à
désirer puisqu' réalité 86% des dossiers
financiers en 2021 par mois privé rénove
concerne le remplacement du système de
chauffage alors qu'il existe en France 2
millions 8 de passoire thermique l'enjeu
est réel l'ADEME relève notamment que
rénover un logement en une seule fois
permet d'éviter la création de pont
thermique la probabilité d'atteindre une
performance énergétique élevée se réduit
d'autant plus que les étapes de
rénovation c'est selon dans le temps
plus préoccupant encore rénover rénover
son système de chauffage avant son
isolation peut conduire à un
surdimensionnement du système
occasionnant paradoxalement une
surconsommation et une usure précoce du
matériel à l'inverse faire primer les
travaux d'isolation favorise les
économies d'énergie et le confort
thermique du logement
si la priorité n'est pas donnée à
l'isolation le seul atout de ma prime
rénove sera de permettre à nos
concitoyens de chauffer les rues au
pellets plutôt qu'au fuel au lieu de
chauffer l'horlogements une alternative
crédible à cette problématique serait
d'imposer comme pour ma prive rénovénie
sérénité un gars énergétique minimum
voire d'exiger la réalisation de
certains gestes pour bénéficier de la
prime comme l'impôt déjà la réduction
d'impôts de Normandie dans son domaine
ma question est donc simple comment
entendez-vous rééquilibrer ma prime
rénov afin d'encourager les travaux
d'isolation ainsi que la multiplication
des gestes pour chaque dossier merci
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le ministre
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée
je tiens à le redire ma prime rénov
permet de réduire efficacement les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre des
logements individuels ce dispositif est
associé à une économie d'énergie
annuelle de 5,5 mégawatts par logement
aidé dans un contexte de hausse des prix
d'énergie mais après manœuvre contribue
activement à sortir des énergies
fossiles en logement individuel mais oui
vous avez raison il faut aller plus loin
et accompagner
l'habitat collectif avec de nouveaux
dispositifs c'est l'enjeu qui est celui
des années qui viennent à la fois pour
l'individuel parce que le monogès n'est
pas suffisant il faut aller vers des
rénovations performantes puis globale
mais aussi pour les l'habitat collectif
dans lequel il faut faire évoluer les
règles de la copropriété pour rendre
l'accès à ces chantiers plus facile et
limité comme ça déjà été dit plusieurs
fois le reste à charge pour que les
copropriétés devant la connaissance
parfaite des travaux à mener puissent
prendre la décision en toute
connaissance de cause donc c'est l'enjeu
des années qui viennent à la fois
continuer la massification aller vers
une rénovation performante puis globale
et donner tous les outils à la
copropriété et à l'ibita collectif on a
parlé du logement social tout à l'heure
mais les situations différentes pour que
les copropriétaires puissent lancer les
chantiers avec la plus grande
connaissance des causes et puis bien
évidemment pour sortir des logements en
habitat collectif en F et G bien souvent
il suffira pas de faire des rénovations
à l'intérieur de l'appartement mais
simplement seulement si l'ensemble de la
copropriété a voté et s'est mis en ordre
de marche pour lancer des travaux à
l'échelle de la copropriété et des
parties communes je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Guignot
merci Madame présidente j'appelle la
tension du monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires sur les conséquences
financières et sociales de la loi climat
et résilience pour les petits
propriétaires bailleurs depuis le 1er
janvier 2023 les propriétaires dont le
bien et diagnostiqué en G et dont la
consommation énergétique dépasse
pardon dépasse les 450 kWh par an ne
peuvent plus louer de plus depuis l'été
dernier les loyers ne peuvent plus être
augmentés pour ceux classés en G ou en F
cela concerne 6,9 millions de logements
aurions-nous près de 7 millions de
logements indécents en France les
propriétaires parfois âgées dont les
bâtiments doivent être mis en conformité
avec la loi du 22 août 2021 devront
assumer le coût des travaux et des fonds
propres qui ne sont pas toujours issus
de leurs revenus fonciers ils devront le
plus souvent emprunter sur de longues
années pour réaliser ses travaux ils les
seront donc en héritage les mensualités
de remboursement à leurs au lieu d'un
petit patrimoine immobilier en effet
vous avez cédé aux exigences délirantes
des Verts vous avez mis en place un
système qui empêche les petits
propriétaires de bénéficier de revenus
souvent complémentaires alors faible
retraite ne pouvant plus être loué les
biens des peuples petits propriétaires
seront mis en vente à des prix
dérisoires et récupérer par des
marchands de sommeil puisque notamment
dans la ruralité les loyers sont plus
faibles alors que les coûts de
rénovation sont identiques ceci est une
partie des conséquences de votre
soumission au dogme des écologistes
extrémistes en refusant de quitter le
carcan énergétique européen vous êtes
devenus des affameurs du peuple pire
encore demain avec les Verts vous serez
ceux qui vont spolier l'héritage de nos
enfants monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous agir pour supprimer les
effets pervers et injuste de cette loi
qui sous le couvert de la rénovation
énergétique va encore réduire les
revenus et déposséder des milliers de
Français n'ajoutez pas de la colère de
la colère
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
d'abord quand on est propriétaire on a
des obligations et la première des
obligations c'est de loger dignement
c'est locataires lorsqu'on encaisse des
loyers et loger dans une passoire
thermique voir dans un taudis thermique
ça ne répond pas aux obligations moi je
j'ai été il y a encore quelques semaines
maire de Clichy-sous-Bois et je peux
vous assurer qu'à certains nombre de
propriétaires que vous ne qualifiez pas
de marchands de sommeil en sont alors on
peut dire propriétaire indélicat mais en
tout cas ils sont des marchands de
sommeil sans le savoir peut-être et
lorsqu'on a des enfants dans ces
appartements soumis à l'humidité soumis
à la moisissure et bien c'est de la
responsabilité d'un propriétaire de
faire les travaux pour que les personnes
qui logent soient logées décemment oui
ils sont ils ont accès aux aides et les
propriétaires bailleurs ont accès aux
aides parce que la loi a été améliorée
ils ont encaissé des loyers pendant un
certain temps et c'est normal
qu'ils répondent à leurs obligations de
propriétaires et ne permettent pas alors
locataires de souffrir de l'humidité du
froid en hiver et de la grande chaleur
en été je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à même cousin
merci à le ministre avant ont bien avant
la crise énergétique que nous
connaissons les collectivités qui sont
tenues de montrer l'exemple en matière
de rénovation thermique et des bâtiments
avait lancé de grands travaux en ce sens
mais ce chantier est loin d'être simple
au regard de la capacité financière à
agir
un stabilité des dotations manque
d'autonomie budgétaire complexité du
montage des dossiers aujourd'hui du fait
de la crise énergétique que traverse la
France la situation est très
préoccupante et bon nombre de projets de
rénovation thermique des bâtiments sont
au point mort tant l'impact leur
fonctionnement entravent leur capacité à
investir que comptez-vous mettre en
oeuvre pour permettre aux collectivités
d'investir dans la rénovation thermique
de leur patrimoine par ailleurs quel
levier allez-vous actionner pour
accompagner ces mêmes collectivités dans
leur soutien au bailleur pour accélérer
la rénovation thermique des logements je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
les bâtiments publics de l'État et des
collectivités locales sont responsables
de trois quarts de la consommation
énergétique des communes le traitement
des bâtiments scolaires qui représentent
50% de leur parc représente un enjeu
important et le président en a fait une
priorité claire
comme pour le tertiaire de manière
générale la rénovation des bâtiments
publics est orienté par le dispositif
réglementaire écho énergétaire qui fixe
des obligations de réduction de la
consommation énergétique aux horizons
2030 2040 2050 jusqu'à - 60% de
réduction des consommations des
programmes ces deux œufs visent
également à massifier la rénovation et
renforcer l'ingénierie 100 millions
d'euros sont notamment dédiés à l'appui
en ingénierie des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre du programme
Action des collectivités territoriales
pour l'efficacité énergétique la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics était une priorité du plan de
relance l'État et les collectivités ont
pu bénéficier d'une enveloppe de 4
milliards d'euros le fond vert doté de 2
milliards d'euros pour 2023 est mise à
disposition des collectivités doit
permettre de prolonger cette dynamique
enfin d'autres sources de financement
notamment privées devront être aussi
mobilisés plus facilement pour parvenir
à atteindre ses objectifs c'est l'enjeu
notamment de la proposition de loi
rapportée par le député Cazenave que
vous examinerez dans les prochains jours
pour faciliter le recours à des
solutions de tiers financement ensuite
enfin et pour terminer vous avez évoqué
le logement social nous l'avons évoqué
en début de séance mais peut-être que
vous n'étiez pas là le logement social
doit faire
dans le cas du pacte de confiance que
nous écrivons avec l'USH faire preuve
d'une capacité à financer la rénovation
thermique de son bâtiment nous avons
inscrit pour le projet de finance 2023
200 millions d'euros dans le cadre de
l'aide à la pierre pour accompagner le
logement social et puis vous le savez
dans les programmes de renouvellement
urbain la rue est très présent aux côtés
des bailleurs sociaux pour rénover leur
parc merci
merci monsieur le ministre nous passons
au groupe la France insoumise la parole
est à Madame trouvée
madame la présente monsieur le mini
chers collègues tout le monde le sait il
y a 7 millions de passoires thermiques
dans ce pays et c'est un vrai fléau
social écologique alors vous nous dites
très fiers nous avons la solution avec
ma prime rénove notamment et vous nous
dites très fier nous avons versé 700 000
primes l'année dernière mais ce sont 700
000 primes qui ne sont ni efficaces ni
rentables qui finance qu'on appelle des
monogèses par exemple des changements de
porte ou chaudière mais qui ne résolvent
absolument pas le problème des passoires
thermiques et de la rénovation globale
la preuve sur les 7 millions de
logements passoire thermique il n'y en a
que 2500 qui sont sortis de ce statut
grâce à ma prime rénov en 2022
si on comptait sur votre système il
faudrait 2000 ans pour sortir des
passoires thermiques avec ma prime rénov
alors quel est le problème et bien
notamment le reste à charge reste trop
important la plupart du temps des
dizaines de milliers d'euros pour une
rénovation globale c'est ce qui nous a
été dit dans les auditions pour préparer
un projet de loi en la matière dans ces
conditions les ménages modestes ne se
lancent pas dans de telles chantiers si
on veut accélérer les rénovations
globales il faut réduire ce reste à
charge pour les propriétaires modestes
et même le réduire à zéro c'est ce que
la France insoumise et la nupesse ont
proposé voté en commission en novembre
et que vous autres avez repoussé et
contrairement à ce que vous dites
souvent les acteurs du bâtiment nous
disent qu'ils sont prêts ils pourront
assumer cette nouvelle demande et
créeront d'ailleurs beaucoup d'emplois
la matière et pour ça il faut un soutien
public qui soit bien plus conséquent et
programmé sur plusieurs années c'est
pourquoi une majorité de députés avaient
voté 12 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements en 2023
vous les avez retoqués par le biais d'un
49,3 résultat il n'y a seulement que 2
milliards et demi affectés à ma prime
rénove en 2023 à peine plus qu'en 2022
c'est une misère au regard des objectifs
que vous avez fixé comment donc
comptez-vous les atteindre par quel
miracle monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
vous savez que le gouvernement s'inscrit
dans une démarche de planification
énergétique inspirée par la première
ministre que nous appelons France nation
verte et qui va nous guider pour revenir
au passoire énergétique elles sont et
vous avez raison de le dire un fléau et
le gouvernement est mobilisé pour les
éradiquer il n'est pas acceptable et je
venais de le dire que nos concitoyens
vivent dans ce qui s'apparent parfois à
un taudis énergétique au 1er janvier
2022 sur les 30 millions de résidences
principales environ 5,2 millions de
logements soit
17%, seraient dépasseoirs énergétiques
avec un DPE de classe F ou G les aides
m'imprimeraient 9 sont orientées vers
l'éradication des passoires énergétiques
et permettent d'obtenir un bonus
financier lorsque les travaux permettent
de sortir des classes F et G
permettez-moi de vous redire que ce
chiffre de 2500 est un chiffre qui est
erroné c'est le chiffre du bonus mais
c'est bien évidemment bien plus de
logements qui sont sortis de de cette
passoire mais qui n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'une demande de bonus et celle de 1500
logements ont fait l'objet de cette
demande le dispositif m'a prime rénov
sérénité a permis de rénover de façon
globale en 2022 plus de 19000 logements
en classe F et G sur les 352 dossiers
financiers financés pardon soit plus de
50 %. ma prime rénove a été étendue à
l'ensemble des propriétaires de
logements en 2021 y compris et on en
parlait il y a quelques secondes au
propriétaire bailleurs afin de soutenir
l'installation de système de chauffage
fonctionnant à l'aide d'énergie
renouvelable l'effort fait ma prime
rénov ont été renforcés dans le cadre du
plan de résilience de 1000 euros ce
renforcement a été prolongé jusqu'au 31
mars 2023 d'autres dispositifs viennent
complément compléter les subventions de
travaux les C2E et les éco-prés à taux
zéro notamment pour l'ensemble des
ménages et qu'aux prêt à taux zéro je
vous rappelle qu'ils sont maintenant
couplés avec les demandes de subvention
ma pour simplifier les démarches
les premières estimations des services
monde que ma prime rénov bénéficierait à
environ environ 25% des passoires soit
plus de 150 000 logements ont bénéficié
pardon à plus de 150 000 logements en
2022 merci merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur David bonjour
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
alors la consommation d'énergie du
secteur résidentiel représente 20% des
émissions de CO2 et 31% de la
consommation nationale d'énergie après
avoir augmenté très fortement jusqu'au
début des années 2000 cette consommation
tend à se stabiliser depuis avec une
légère baisse de 5%. entre 2012 et 2019
mais cette baisse est largement
insuffisante au regard des enjeux
climatiques et aussi au regard des
enjeux géostratégiques de souveraineté
énergétique il faut donc changer de
braquet et de méthode le dispositif
m'imprimer étant à ce stade incapable de
permettre et nécessaire 700 000
rénovations par an que nous devons faire
alors commençons étape par étape par les
diagnostics énergétiques que propose le
gouvernement pour qu'il soit plus fiable
et systématique est-ce qu'il n'est pas
tant de relancer un véritable service
public du bâtiment qui les prenne en
charge au vu du nombre de problèmes et
de fiasco de que qu'on pointait les
associations consommateurs ensuite les
rénovations ciblées sont insuffisantes
et parfois même contre-productives que
propose le gouvernement pour faciliter
non plus des rénovations juste sur les
fenêtres ou sur un autre aspect de ma
prime rénov mais des rénovations
globales qui intègrent la rénovation
thermique dans des projets plus larges
lutte contre la salubrité et à Marseille
je le sais c'est vraiment fondamental
conforme et aussi modification de
l'habitat il faut réellement réintégrer
la question de la rénovation thermique
dans une rénovation beaucoup plus
globale enfin le reste à charge est trop
important pour de nombreux petits
propriétaires que compte faire le
gouvernement pour augmenter la part
d'aide de l'État le gouvernement ne l'a
pas à pas retenu la propriété la
proposition que nous avions fait avec 12
milliards et comment vous allez vous
faire pour pour réellement cueiller les
moyens pour réduire cette ce reste à
charge ensuite il faut faciliter l'accès
au crédit il est aujourd'hui plus facile
de bénéficier d'un crédit pour acheter
un logement que pour rénover est-ce que
c'est normal monsieur le ministre enfin
la loi prévoit prévoit uniquement de
classer des logements GF et E comme des
logements indécents avec le risque les
propriétaires se tournent vers la
location saisonnière non concernés la
loi et enfin les sanctions notamment
contre les 3,5% de multipropriétaires
qui possèdent 50% des logements loyers
sont insuffisantes que comptez-vous
faire pour que ces multipropriétaires
rénovent leur logement qui sont des fois
des passoires thermiques merci Monsieur
David la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés plusieurs
plusieurs questions pour ce qui est de
la copropriété je l'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois oui l'habitat collectif
et la rénovation de l'habitat collectif
est une priorité et il faut améliorer
les différents dispositifs pour
accompagner mieux les copropriétés et
les copropriétaires pour baisser le
reste à charge c'est c'est où lorsqu'il
y a reste à charge à travers les prêts
et les éco-prés permettent aux
copropriétaires de réaliser les travaux
et d'avoir un vote positif c'est le sens
de rencontres que nous n'avons prévues
de faire avec les banquiers pour que les
banques s'intéressent à nouveau plus aux
copropriétés il y avait un certain
nombre de dispositifs d'avance qui ont
parfois disparu et sur lequel je
souhaite que les banques reviennent la
Caisse d'Epargne le fait mais le fait
pas suffisamment notamment la Caisse
d'Épargne Île-de-France et il faut que
d'autres banques accompagnent les
copropriétés et les copropriétaires pour
réaliser ses travaux enfin nous avons
décidé d'augmenter le niveau d'aide
pour les copropriétés les passer de 15 à
25000 euros pour que ces aides puissent
permettre d'aller plus loin sur sur les
rénovations thermiques enfin vous avez
raison il faut continuer à travailler
sur le DPE qui est un outil essentiel de
compréhension de la qualité du logement
et de son évolution et donc avec la
crise qui se déroule sous nos yeux le
meilleur outil le meilleur thermomètre
que nous avons pour connaître la
situation d'un logement c'est celle
c'est celle du DPE sur lequel nous
allons continuer à travailler il a une
refonte des dps en 2021 il a été
entièrement repensé c'est aujourd'hui un
outil qui est robuste fiable et
performant sur lequel nous allons
pouvoir nous appuyer dans la cadre de
toutes nos politiques de rénovation du
parc et l'autre outil sur lequel on
s'appuie c'est les entreprises dont on a
été plusieurs fois question tout au long
de cet après-midi il faut continuer à
développer la filière continuer à
qualifier les entreprises qu'elles
accèdent au RGE pour qu'elles puissent
être plus nombreuses dans le dans le
champ de la rénovation je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur cloué
madame la Présidente collègue monsieur
le ministre notre discussion depuis tout
à l'heure pose une question qui est
effectivement incontournable la question
de savoir combien ça coûte on se demande
combien ça coûte de changer des fenêtres
combien ça coûte de refaire des toitures
ou des planchers combien ça coûte de
modifier un équipement de chauffage mais
cette question prend dès lors le sujet
par le petit bout la lorgnette car la
vraie interrogation est de savoir
combien ça coûte de ne pas faire tout
cela et c'est là dessus que je
souhaiterais vous interroger monsieur le
ministre combien est-ce que cela coûte à
notre pays d'avoir des millions de
personnes qui vivent dans le froid
combien est-ce que cela coûte en terme
de maladies d'avoir des enfants qui sont
atteints d'asthme qui soit atteints de
bronchite qui sont atteints de pneumonie
combien est-ce que ça coûte à notre pays
d'avoir des personnes qui n'arrivent pas
à faire mais l'œil de la nuit alors
qu'elles doivent le lendemain se rendre
sur leur lieu de travail ou aller
étudier combien ça coûte à notre pays
d'avoir des enfants qui au moment de
réviser le soir pour leur cours du
lendemain doivent le faire dans la quasi
obscurité doivent le faire dans une
chambre qui parfois pas sans le moisi où
doivent le faire sans pouvoir ouvrir la
fenêtre parce que la concentration dans
le logement de particules fines ou de
produits polluants et tout à fait
excessive et les empoisonnent combien ça
coûte au pays plus généralement de
laisser un certain nombre et vous le
savez la DC CRF
appelle régulièrement être attentif
combien ça coûte à laisser un grand
nombre d'escrocs mener des chantiers à
la va-vite car les personnes les
particules n'ont pas l'argent de pouvoir
faire la réflexion en un seul coup de
manière de manière intégrée de bout en
bout bref combien ça coûte d'avoir une
situation où nous avons plus de 2000
morts par an uniquement parce qu'il est
parce qu'elles vivent chez eux dans le
froid dans ce qu'on appelle dans le cas
de notre débat il ne passoire thermique
donc combien est-ce que cela coûte
d'avoir une inaction gouvernementale et
d'avoir un retard dans l'ensemble des
engagements qui sont pris vis-à-vis de
la population question d'autant plus
urgente que la majorité relative a
adopter un texte de loi antilocataire
pourtant dans le parc social ce ne sont
que 7% des logements qui sont des
passoires thermiques alors savoir que
dans le parc privé c'est près d'un car
là aussi encore une fois le public fait
mieux pour moins cher merci monsieur le
ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je partage avec
vous l'analyse que la question de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments n'est
pas qu'une question d'argent bien
évidemment c'est d'abord une question
sociale donc quelles conditions nous
laissons vivre nos concitoyens
l'objectif du gouvernement de plus de
700 000 logements rénovés par an est un
objectif qui aujourd'hui est faisable si
dans les années qui viennent on peut
tenir des objectifs plus importants et
bien on s'en donnera les moyens mais je
peux vous assurer que il suffit pas de
d'être dans l'incantation je crois pas
que c'est ce qui était votre propos pour
se dire demain on va pouvoir rénover un
million 2 millions de logements en une
année vous le savez moi je je le dis
souvent je suis d'abord un petit maire
de Clichy-sous-Bois qui connaît la
situation de l'habitat collectif que ça
soit dans l'habitat social ou dans les
copropriétés dégradées
leur code de Clichy sous Bois une
opération d'intérêt nationale c'est pas
un problème d'argent aujourd'hui on a
l'argent mais rénové un immeuble rénové
totalement en immeuble c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement complexe et
qui demande de l'ingénierie de la
préparation et des et des préparations
de chantier extrêmement importants
est-ce qu'on peut le faire en site
occupé est-ce qu'on peut pas le faire en
site occupé donc je crois vraiment que
on a une volonté partagée d'aller plus
vite plus loin sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments donnons-nous les
moyens de qualifier la filière
donnons-nous les moyens de qualifier le
niveau travaux nécessaires oui allons
vers des rénovations plus globale plus
performante d'abord performante puis
globale pour répondre à l'urgence
réglons d'abord en urgence la question
des taudis dépasseoirs énergétiques et
en même temps continuons ensemble à
lutter contre l'habitat insalubre et
contre les marchands de sommeil et nous
aurons en partie avancée mais il n'est
pas qu'une question d'argent aujourd'hui
pour aller plus vite sur la rénovation
des bâtiments je vous de me croire je
vous remercie merci monsieur le ministre
nous passons au groupe les républicains
la parole est à Madame peut être levée
merci à madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre à mes chers collègues la
rénovation énergétique est plus
précisément thermique de nos bâtiments
est un des enjeux les plus importants de
notre époque elle se heurte
malheureusement à plusieurs limites
premièrement le pilotage des politiques
publiques en matière de rénovation
thermique ne conduit pas à des résultats
pertinents et montrent des limites
criantes la plupart du temps c'est le
nombre de logements rénovés elle est
dépenses publiques qui sont pris en
considération plutôt que la baisse de la
consommation énergétique et des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
n'existe aucune statistique en France
basée sur les consommations réelles
après rénovation thermique ce système
est non seulement préjudiciable à la
performance énergétique mais également
au suivi des politiques certes l'État a
proposé un éventail d'aide aux Français
une quinzaine environ mais combien
d'entre eux les ont perçus on m'a
souvent signalé d'ailleurs des
procédures administratives compliquées
et interminables cela constitue
actuellement un vrai frein pour de
nombreux ménages à se lancer dans des
travaux de rénovation énergétique il
semble aujourd'hui indispensable de
clarifier de simplifier les différents
dispositifs d'aide et les démarches à
suivre
deuxièmement dans le cadre de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
d'habitation ne serait-il pas pertinent
d'insister d'inciter voire imposer aux
propriétaires d'un même immeuble à
rénover l'entièreté du bâtiment pour
obtenir de vrais résultats énergétiques
et éviter les gestes isolés et à moindre
effet enfin le marché de l'immobilier va
être chamboulé par l'interdiction à la
location des logements mal classés
énergétiquement qui va se durcir dans
les années à venir cette mesure
entendable mais aussi alerte depuis des
mois la filière du BTP à travers la
quantité massive de logements à rénover
l'offre devient considérablement faible
face à la demande croissante les
artisans l'annoncent tant en termes de
main d'oeuvre que de matériaux les
travaux de rénovation thermique
s'enchaînent et ne peuvent
malheureusement pas suivre aussi et dans
le contexte d'explosion des tarifs de
l'électricité pour les professionnels
que nous connaissons comment le
gouvernement quand il pallier au manque
d'artisan et de matériaux qui va
fortement freiner les travaux de
rénovation énergétique des particuliers
depuis des années la puissance publique
multiplie les chèques pour des
dispositifs qui nous donnent pas
vraiment satisfaction au bénéficiaire ni
tradition du législateur de massifier la
rénovation thermique dans notre pays
entre incitation et obligations il est
grand temps de trouver un fonctionnement
équilibré et véritablement efficace
merci merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
[Musique]
vous avez vous avez raison je crois
avoir essayé de le dire tout au long de
cet après-midi
la rénovation de l'habitat collectif ne
passe pas par la rénovation ou en tout
cas uniquement par la rénovation d'un
logement à l'intérieur d'un habitat
collectif l'enjeu qui est le nôtre celui
que l'on mène avec Lana c'est de
qualifier les chantiers nécessaires dans
une copropriété mettre en place le plan
prévisionnel de travaux à l'intérieur de
la copropriété pour que l'ensemble des
copropriétaires soient éclairés des
travaux nécessaires dans leur
copropriété pour avoir un gain
énergétique fiable aujourd'hui avec ma
prime rénov copropriété nous avons un
certain nombre d'outils des outils que
nous devons améliorer tant en termes de
gouvernance de la copropriété la
simplification d'obtenir des votes de
travaux et bien évidemment pour obtenir
des votes de travaux il faut aussi se
donner les moyens de baisser le reste à
charge c'est un travail que l'on mène
avec avec Lana dévolution des
dispositifs d'aide à l'intérieur de la
copropriété vous savez une cop propriété
peut aller très bien mais avoir à
l'intérieur des ménages plus ou moins
modestes et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
faut différencier l'aide aux
copropriétaires en fonction de leurs
revenus soit c'est la copropriété qui
encaisse la totalité des aides et qui
fait une répartition différenciée soit
c'est le copropriétaire qui est ensuite
il y a des copropriétés plus modestes
plus fragiles qui peuvent être dans des
dispositifs type opération programmées
de l'amélioration de l'habitat et des
OPA ou d'autres copropriétés encore plus
fragiles qui peuvent se retrouver dans
des plantes sauvegarde et dans chacun
des cas il faut avoir un niveau d'aide
suffisant pour que ces travaux soient
réalisés c'est l'intérêt des gens qui
habitent pour leur pouvoir d'achat mais
c'est aussi l'intérêt de la planète
puisque chacun de ces gestes auront un
effet sur la diminution des gaz à effet
de serre c'est tout l'enjeu qui est le
nôtre devant nous allez vers des
éco-gestes plus massifs sortir du geste
unique et aller vers des rénovations à
la fois globales et performantes en
particulier dans l'habitat collectif je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole à
Monsieur signéry
merci madame la Présidente sur le
ministre la loi pour la transition
énergétique de 2015 fixé à 2025 un
objectif de disparition totale des 12
millions de passoire thermique de notre
pays cet objectif a été repoussé à 2028
par la loi climat et résilience de 2021
il ne sera pourtant probablement pas
tenu même malgré ce report de calendrier
la Cour des comptes constatée en effet
en mars dernier que depuis le lancement
de ma prime rénoble le 1er janvier 2020
seul 2500 passant thermique ont été
rénovés chaque année dans notre pays on
est donc très loin du compte en octobre
dernier le Défenseur des droits annoncé
publiquement avoir été saisi de près de
500 réclamations en deux ans suite à des
difficultés rencontrées par des ménages
ayant sollicité une aide au titre de ce
programme outre les bugs récurrents sur
la plateforme en ligne les propriétaires
dénoncent l'absence interlocuteur ou
d'informations pour le suivi de leur
dossier des retards compromettants dans
le versement des aides qui peuvent les
conduire à de graves difficultés
financières et des délais anormaux de
traitement qui ont laissé de nombreux
ménages sans chauffage lors des derniers
hivers combien sommes-nous dans cette
hémicycle à avoir reçu des témoignages
de nos concitoyens victimes d'un
dialogue de sourd avec l'administration
de l'État incapable de leur dire ou en
étiez leur dossier et quand ils
pourraient aboutir la gestion de
l'instruction des du dossier normalement
d'évoluer à Lana a été sous-traitée à un
prestataire privé avec qui le dialogue
semble inexistant le choix d'une
plateforme entièrement dématérialisée
sans interlocuteur pour pouvoir se
renseigner ou corriger des erreurs
laisse bon nombre de nos concitoyens à
l'écart du dispositif et oblige les
rares candidats qui osent se lancer à
les taper à la porte de leur pour
espérer débloquer la situation enfin la
complexité du dispositif et le caractère
illisible des aides proposées abouties
fréquemment à des mauvaises surprises à
la fin avec des primes inférieures aux
estimations réalisées avant travaux et
pour toi promis par l'État je conclus
maintenant
ben non mais je comprends mais bon c'est
pour c'est pour ce monde pareil merci
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
d'abord un mot je l'ai je lisais tout à
l'heure sur ces 2500 chiffres qui
courent trop souvent les 2500
rénovations globale sont des rénovations
qui ont fait l'objet du bonus et plus de
160 000 logements ont eu cette
rénovation globale qui aurait pu faire
l'objet d'une bonus mais les autres
propriétaires n'ont pas fait la demande
donc ne restons pas sur ce chiffre qui
est largement minoré de de la réalité
enfin vous m'interrogez sur les dossiers
ma prime rénov en difficulté et vous
avez raison il y a eu un certain nombre
de difficultés le processus et le volume
de traitement des dossiers ma prime
rénov induit nécessairement une part de
dossiers en difficulté il y a une
instruction rigoureuse détaillée et
individualisée de chaque dossier afin de
s'assurer que la demande d'aide est
conforme et que l'argent public est donc
dépensé à bon escient et je pense que
nous en sommes tous nous y sommes tous
extrêmement favorables je le rappelle le
traitement des dossiers et massif
jusqu'à 25000 décisions par semaine j'en
profite pour saluer les équipes de Lana
et l'ensemble de ces agents pour ce
travail important et de qualité qui est
menée ensuite Lana a mis en oeuvre
depuis 2021 un ensemble de parcours et
de processus spécifiques pour traiter
les dossiers en difficulté les agents
sont dans une démarche proactive pour
anticiper les difficultés avec une
sécurisation de la plateforme qu'un
accompagnement systématique renforcé des
usages des usagers pardon en difficulté
enfin je tiens à vous indiquer que nous
avons rencontré renforcé par dans la
lutte contre la fraude car celle-ci
générer des délais de traitement des
dossiers plus longs pour les usagers et
donc une perception de difficulté donc
ne soyons pas pessimiste ma prime
manœuvre ça marche je ne dis pas un
certain nombre de difficultés mais elle
représente à peine 2% des 150 000
dossiers déposés chaque année
merci Monsieur Miss la parole de
Monsieur minot merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre le
financement de travaux de rénovation est
une prise de risque importante pour un
ménage le fait qu'il y ait un reste à
charge nous avons été nombreux à le dire
même après l'attribution d'aide publique
est un général un frein et cela permet
de décourager certains langages des
travaux la création en 2009 d'un
éco-prêt à taux zéro était d'une
initiative prometteuse pour faciliter le
financement de ces opérations par les
Français pourtant seule 61000 éco-prés à
taux zéro ont été accordés en 2021
principalement d'ailleurs à déménager
contre 70 000 l'année de sa création
café le gouvernement pour favoriser
réellement la distribution de ses prêts
les banques ont parfois du mal à jouer
le jeu étant à appliquer les mêmes
conditions que pour un prêt ordinaire
notamment en sur vérifiant la
solvabilité des emprunteurs mais les
banques dénoncent aussi fréquemment la
complexité du dispositif ce qui est en
revanche de la responsabilité directe du
gouvernement
où en est le prêt d'ailleurs avance
rénovation distribué par un nombre trop
peu TV pardon de banque qui permet au
ménage de nous rembourser l'emprunt
qu'au moment de la vente du bien va-t-on
enfin d'ailleurs tenir compte des
économies d'énergie qui sont le
principal atout d'une rénovation
thermique dont le financement de ces
opérations ces travaux sont censés
permettre des économies d'énergie dont
une baisse de la facture pourquoi ce
pouvoir d'achat supplémentaire n'est-il
jamais pris en compte dans le calcul de
la capacité des ménages à rembourser
leur prêt n'est-il pas tant enfin
d'étudier la possibilité de faire appel
à d'autres financeurs éventuels on parle
souvent de créer des opérations ensemble
liées qui financerait et réaliserait à
la fois les travaux en avançant la
totalité des frais seul apporter la
dette il se rembourserait donc sur la
baisse de la facture des ménages et un
fonds publics de garantie prendrait
éventuellement à sa charge des surcos en
cas d'échec ce serait largement plus
économique que toutes les aides que
distribuer l'État depuis des années avec
un succès d'ailleurs relatif et bien
plus incitatif pour les qui n'aurait
plus besoin de s'endetter pour pouvoir
avancer ses travaux vous prétendez
d'ailleurs vouloir massifier la
rénovation thermique qu'avez-vous fait
pour étudier sérieusement cette solution
nouvelle de financement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous avez raison le la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments est une
responsabilité collective et elle doit
être partagée d'ailleurs la mise en
place du service public France rénov
montre un traitement assez différencié
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
suivant la manière dont les
collectivités locales avaient prises en
compte la question de la réhabilitation
thermique des bâtiments certains
départements certaines métropoles
certains EPCI ont mis en place des
outils d'aide important avaient déjà mis
en place leur propre Alec alors que
d'autres étaient bien en retard et ce
qui fait que aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national on peut avoir une
différenciation des aides lorsque des
aides viennent les aides de l'État
viennent s'ajouter aux aides des
collectivités locales ou lorsque les
aides des de l'État ne vient s'ajouter à
rien et moi je crois que cette
responsabilité doit être plus marqué et
par moment il faut aussi signifier
lorsque des collectivités locales ne se
sont pas assez engagés voir ce sont des
engagés des dispositifs d'aide à la
rénovation thermique du bâtiments et
d'ailleurs lorsque nous travaillerons à
la décentralisation de la question du
logement et de ces différents outils je
pense que c'est différenciation devront
être marqué ensuite pour ce qui est des
banques je crois que vous avez raison il
y a une responsabilité des banques
d'être plus présent à la fois pour
accompagner les copropriétés et
accompagner les copropriétaires c'est un
enjeu majeur puisque dans le cadre du
plan pluriannuel des travaux qui doivent
être votés par une copropriété cette
visibilité doit être aussi connue au
regard de la solvabilité ou de la
capacité d'une banque d'aide présente et
c'est l'objet d'un travail que l'on mène
avec les banques un certain nombre de
banques s'engage à nos côtés sur les
coupes et TZ d'autres vont venir et je
les annoncé il y a quelques semaines
nous allons réunir l'ensemble des
banquiers avec le ministre Bruno Le
Maire pour échanger de leur capacité à
intervenir avec nous sur les
copropriétés et être plus présentes dans
l'accompagnement de ses copropriétés
dans le cas des travaux de rénovation
mais tout simplement dans le cadre des
travaux notamment sur les parties
communes je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre nous passons au groupe
libertins indépendant outre-mer et
territoire la parole est à Monsieur
Bricout merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre nous débattons
aujourd'hui d'un sujet dont les enjeux
sont bien sûr essentiels pour la France
Les Français et la planète des enjeux
sociaux pensant au 12 millions de nos
concitoyens calfeutrés dans leur
logement des enjeux écologiques le
logement c'est 25% des gaz à effet de
serre et 45% des consommations d'énergie
des enjeux économiques la rénovation
c'est de l'activité pour le secteur du
bâtiment notre économie de proximité des
enjeux aussi de souveraineté
énergétiques puisque consommer moins
c'est produire moins et faciliter notre
autonomie parce que l'urgence climatique
rejoint aujourd'hui l'urgence sociale la
rénovation des logements est donc la
priorité des priorités et c'est avant
tout je crois une volonté politique
monsieur le ministre cette volonté le
gouvernement l'exprime avec ma prime
rénov certes avec un certains succès
mais une efficacité partielle oui une
prime rénove n'est pas une rénovation
les politiques par gestes nous
permettent pas d'être sur le bon rythme
pour obtenir le neutralité carbone pour
2050 pourtant en 2019 déjà je vous
proposais avec mon collègue Boris Vallot
un dispositif suffisamment puissant au
déclenchement des travaux de façon
massive nouveau proposions d'abord
l'approche d'une rénovation globale et
performante du logement un
accompagnement renforcé tout au long des
travaux du diagnostic jusqu'à la
réception du chantier et surtout un
financement innovant de l'assiette
globale des travaux une part de
subventions forfaitaire 30 à 50% suivant
la situation sociale de l'occupant et le
reste à charge financé par une avance
remboursée au moment de la mutation du
bien la vente ou la succession une
méthode d'ailleurs de financement qui
était à l'époque encensé par Monsieur
Sichel président de la CDC est chargé de
mission sur le sujet trois ans donc
après notre initiative vous commencez à
convenir de nos propositions que ce soit
sur la rénovation globale ou sur le prêt
avance et tant mieux je vais dire ouais
on a quelquefois le sentiment d'être
copié mais c'est quelque part un honneur
c'est comme toutes les marques il faut
le dire
et c'est aussi je pense à réconfort pour
ceux qui attendent dans le froid
monsieur le ministre pas question est
simple entendez-vous remettre sur le
chantier cette proposition l'améliorer
encore avec cette approche globale et
massive et aussi travailler sur dans le
même le même esprit sur les copropriétés
je reste à votre disposition merci
Monsieur Bricout monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
la loi climat et résilience a créé un
dispositif complémentaire pour financer
le reste à charge de travaux de
rénovation énergétique réalisée par des
potions des professionnels reconnus
garant de l'environnement rgge distribué
sous le nom du prêt avance rénovation se
prêtent permet de différer le
remboursement du capital emprunté à la
mutation ce prêt est destiné
prioritairement au public qui ne
pourraient pas emprunter dans des
conditions classiques notamment les
ménages aux revenus modestes la loi
climat et résilience permet également au
fond de garantie pour la rénovation
énergétique excusez-moi
de couvrir jusqu'à 75% du risque de
perte du crédit accordée aux ménage sous
conditions de ressources modestes le
prêt avance rénovation est complètement
opérationnelle depuis février 2022 de
banque trois banques pardon ont d'ores
et déjà commencer son déploiement et
d'autres travaillent à la distribution
de ce produit dans les prochains mois en
2022 les premiers chiffres indiquent que
36 parts ont été émis avec un montant
moyen de 20860 euros par ménage c'est
encore trop faible et nous n'en sommes
qu'au démarrage de ce dispositif qui
doit être mieux présenté et plus connu
les retours d'expérience vont nous
permettre d'identifier les évolutions
qui permettraient de développer
davantage ce dispositif je continuerai à
mobiliser les banques pour renforcer la
distribution la distribution de ce
dispositif et le faire connaître à ce
titre je souligne les évolutions dont
j'ai déjà parlé que nous avons mises en
œuvre pour simplifier l'accès à l'écho
PTZ qui constitue une solution de
financement gratuite pour les ménages en
capacité de rembourser leur capital au
fil de l'eau et en simplifiant les
démarches administratives puisque les
documents fournis pour la demande ma
prime rénov seront directement
transmises à la banque dans le cas d'un
écho PTZ je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Lenormand
le président monsieur le ministre
comment massifier la rénovation
thermique au-delà des mots il y a la
mise en œuvre des politiques publiques
et il nous faut sans doute là plus de
souplesse de pragmatisme et de cohérence
le 6 octobre dernier le gouvernement a
présenté le plan de sobriété énergétique
pour les ménages le programme s'articule
autour de 15 mesures phares destinées à
mieux gérer la consommation et elles
peuvent s'accompagner d'un dispositif
d'un soutien financier cependant
l'archipel de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
par sa spécificité statutée on ne pourra
pas bénéficier de ces mesures d'aide
aussi afin de pouvoir inclure mon
territoire dans cette démarche au
combien importante j'avais proposé un
amendement sur le budget 2023 au niveau
du ministère des Outre-mer justement
pour permettre à la collectivité
territoriale de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
d'impulser ce travail de rénovation et
de massification thermique de la
rénovation thermique de ne part parce
qu'il y avait l'urgence de la situation
avec l'explosion des prix du carburant
parce que le budget démén à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et le plus
impacté par le chauffage entre 30 et 40%
parce que la collectivité a fait un
effort de diagnostic de l'ensemble du
bâti qu'elle a doté le territoire d'un
point il faut une énergie qu'elle a les
outils de diagnostic dévaluation qu'elle
a entamé les formations auprès des
différentes entreprises du bâtiment et
que les dispositifs d'aide sont prêts il
était donc assez logique d'impulser une
aide de l'État à côté de cette volonté
territoriale l'amendement a été voté
puis retiré au nom du 49-3 et ce matin
hasard du calendrier j'ai reçu une autre
réponse du ministre de l'Outre-mer sur
le prix des énergies qui dans un
non-réponse du reste m'incitait à la
rénovation thermique alors vous
comprendrez bien que les bras m'en sont
un peu tombés je parlais de cohérence à
ma connaissance vous êtes dans le même
gouvernement donc dans cet esprit qui
nous anime aujourd'hui et dans le sujet
monsieur le ministre comment faut-il que
je fasse ou à quel saint dois-je me
vouer pour que c'était de puisse arriver
à la collectivité pour lui permettre
d'atteindre l'objectif qui est le nôtre
et qui est l'objet de ce débat
aujourd'hui merci merci Monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député la mise en place de ma prime
rénov et des coups de pouce des
certificats d'économie d'énergie et ces
deux œufs en métropole et dans les
départements d'outre-mer a permis
d'atteindre de très bons résultats en
matière de geste de rénovation comme on
l'a dit depuis le début de l'après-midi
avec près de 700 000 gestes de
rénovation énergétique financée en 2021
et un financement et un résultat
semblable attendu pour 2022 je comprends
que ce succès incite à solliciter
l'extension de ce dispositif à d'autres
territoires toutefois vous le savez la
situation législative réglementaire de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon est
particulière car elle constitue une
collectivité d'outre-mer régie par
l'article 74 de la Constitution dans ce
contexte la collectivité territoriale de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon est compétente
pour définir elle-même en application de
l'article
lo6414-1 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales les
dispositions applicable sur son
territoire en matière d'impôts de droit
et de taxes ainsi que les politiques
publiques applicables depuis 2008 en
matière de construction d'habitation et
de logements la mise en place d'une
prime de transition énergétique sur le
territoire de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
relève par conséquent de la compétence
de la collectivité territoriale le
programme service d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique le programme Sarr
qui aujourd'hui finance les espaces
conseils France Renov via les
certificats d'économie d'énergie les C2E
et une contribution équivalente des
collectivités territoriales se déploie
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la collectivité
de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et donc
pleinement investi avec l'État dans le
déploiement de l'offre de services
France renomme je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous passons au groupe
socialiste à parenté la parole est à
Monsieur le seul
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le Défenseur
des droits dans une décision du 14
octobre dernier point de plusieurs
dysfonctionnements du dispositif imprime
rénov au détriment des potentiels
bénéficiaires j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer dans ma circonscription des
personnes prises au piège de la
plateforme informatique d'aide certains
usagers ne parvenant pas malgré leur
multiples démarches à enregistrer leur
demande ou à obtenir une réponse
définitive certains ont donc réalisé
leurs travaux sans avant d'avoir pu
faire aboutir leur démarche préalable et
les aides lorsqu'on finalement refusées
ces problèmes techniques les délais de
traitement qui s'appliquent parfois à
certains dossiers portent directement
préjudice au ménage certains demandeurs
choisissent même de repousser leurs
travaux au détriment de leur qualité de
vie la procédure dématérialisée cela a
été dit tout à l'heure n'est pas
toujours efficiente
la Défenseur des droits indique
clairement que le passage progressif au
tout numérique se traduit pour beaucoup
par un recul de l'accès au droit alors
que les ménages devraient être
encouragés rassurées accompagner quelles
mesures allez-vous mettre en place pour
résoudre les actuels dysfonctionnement
vous le savez face aux difficultés de
mise en place de ma prime rénove les
ménages qui décident de faire de la
rénovation thermique le fond font
souvent le choix du petit geste et pour
massifier la rénovation des bâtiments il
conviendrait de mettre en place des
rénovations globales l'isolation des
murs extérieurs du toit changement des
huisseries remplaçant du dispositif de
chauffage cela doit passer par un réel
accompagnement des ménages et des
bailleurs par la réduction des délais de
traitement par la suppression de tout
numérique et le renforcement de
l'accompagnement social technique et
économique pourquoi ne pas avoir
conservé des moyens supplémentaires de
12 milliards d'euros comme nous les
avions adoptés grâce aux amendements des
groupes de gauche dans cette émission
avant votre application du 49-3 que
faites-vous pour développer les
possibilités d'avance réfléchir comme
nous l'avions proposé comme ça vient
d'être rappelé par mon collègue Bricout
tardivement et partiellement repris par
votre gouvernement donc quels sont les
chiffres actuels de distribution du prêt
avance rénovation et êtes-vous prêt à
pousser le développement du pain
uniquement mis en place par deux
établissements bancaires coopératifs je
vous remercie je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
à la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le le député
en essayant de reprendre les questions
dans l'ordre oui il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements j'ai rencontré la
Défenseur des droits je rappelle que son
rapport fait état de 400 dossiers
qu'elle traite au regard des 750 000
dossiers traités chaque année c'est 400
dossiers de trop j'en conviens avec vous
et nous y travaillons et nous
travaillons aussi à ce que les agences
France services qui sont des agences de
proximité de service public puisse
recevoir les les réclamations et faire
le lien entre Lana et et les nos
concitoyens en difficulté et puis vous
avez raison la question de la
dématérialisation ne doit pas introduire
de nouvelles fractures notamment une
fracture numérique qui ferait qu'un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens ne
pourraient pas
disposer de l'accueil dans France dans
les outils françaises donc bien
évidemment
il faut appeler l'agence France rénov de
son territoire et là je peux vous
assurer que c'est simple de trouver le
numéro soit dans sa dans sa mairie soit
sur internet si on n'est pas victime de
fracture numérique et de souhaiter soit
un accompagnement téléphonique soit un
accompagnement physique soit à travers
une agence France rénote ensuite ça a
été dit plusieurs fois vous avez raison
l'implication des banques est une
application extrêmement importante dans
le développement de de notre action en
direction de la rénovation thermique et
l'accès à ma prime rénov ou en tout cas
à au reste à charge et donc c'est pour
ça je le redis qu'une réunion aura lieu
dans les semaines qui viennent entre le
ministre de la Ville et du logement et
le ministère de l'économie et des
finances pour faire un point avec les
banquiers de leur capacité à s'impliquer
plus dans ces dossiers à s'impliquer
plus dans le prêt à taux zéro les
coprées à taux zéro de s'impliquer plus
dans le parc puisque je l'indiquais tout
à l'heure aujourd'hui le niveau
d'intervention du parc est insuffisant
au regard de la qualité de ce dispositif
qui permet l'accès à des prêts à des
ménages modestes et très modestes en
particulier des personnes âgées qui
pourront avoir accès à ce dispositif et
on y reviendra lorsqu'on parlera de ma
Primada merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Madame caraméli
egg même si certains en doutent les
évaluations des résultats des politiques
engagées par plusieurs pays européens
dont l'Allemagne montrent que les
économies d'énergie prévue avant travaux
initialement en moyenne ont
effectivement pu être atteintes en
mesurant les consommations réelles deux
ans après les travaux pourtant donc
l'humanité massification rapide et
rénovations énergétiques très
performantes en s'appuyant sur
différents leviers complémentaires
seraient possible plusieurs points
semblent-ils qu'ils doivent être
améliorés interrogés aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens considèrent que près de la
moitié 47% que les dispositifs
d'incitation et des aides permettant de
s'équiper dans le domaine sont complexe
et réussir donc suppose d'agir sur
plusieurs leviers mettre par exemple en
place un dispositif d'aide unique
combinant prêt et subventions indexées
sur la performance énergétique et
associés à un suivi après travaux cela
existe déjà dans d'autres pays européens
instituer des aides par exemple
conséquentes pour le ménage modeste dans
une logique de transition juste et ce
alors que la crise contraint le pouvoir
d'achat instaurer une obligation de
rénovation élargie telle que la prononcé
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
est lié à la mise en place des
dispositifs d'accompagnement guichet
unique et de financement adapté ou
réussir aussi une structuration de
l'offre de rénovation globale par des
professionnels qualifiés à l'échelle des
territoires capable justement de
répondre à la massification des projets
et surtout de regagner la confiance des
ménages grâce à la réalisation de
qualité intégrant un suivi de la
performance alors surtout ces points nos
concitoyens n'entendent pas opposés
maîtrise de la demande énergie recours à
des énergies renouvelables et des
carbonées il souhaite des résultats
concrets en même temps comme c'est le
terme consacré pouvez-vous donc monsieur
le ministre nous donner une trajectoire
de cette massification avec des
objectifs chiffrés de bâtiment de
famille de montant de travaux et de
diminution de consommation ainsi qu'un
calendrier pouvez-vous nous engager
revenir devant notre assemblée à faire
un bilan exhaustif de cette trajectoire
tous les ans avec un point écrit et
chiffré par semestre adressé à
l'ensemble merci merci
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée permettez-moi
de
d'utiliser votre question pour avoir un
mot plus général sur la planification
écologique pour franchir un nouveau cap
dans notre politique de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments il nous faut
l'inscrire résolument dans l'exercice de
planification énergétique avec France
nation verte la massification des
rénovations performantes suppose d'agir
sur différents plans l'accompagnement la
stimulation de la demande la fluidité
des parcours la structuration de l'offre
de manière coordonnée et dans le temps
avec le ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires avec le ministère de la
transition énergétique sous l'égide de
madame la Première ministre nous avons
identifié plusieurs chantiers qui
relèvent spécifiquement de cet exercice
de planification il viendront évidemment
alimenter dans les prochains mois la loi
de programmation énergie climat et la
stratégie française en la matière en
particulier nous travaillons notamment à
la définition d'une trajectoire
concertée de rénovation du parc de
logement cohérente avec nos objectifs de
moyens et de long terme et qui puissent
servir de référence sur les quinquennats
afin de piloter la dynamique des
rénovations performantes de traitement
des passoires ou encore de sortie des
énergies fossiles
deuxièmement un plan d'action pour
disposer d'une offre à la hauteur de
cette trajectoire ambitieuse en lien
avec la filière dans la continuité des
Assises du bâtiment et des collectivités
à travers le renforcement de la
formation et de l'attractivité des
métiers de l'animation de la filière
pour laquelle nous comptons notamment
sur les régions de sa structuration pour
mieux répondre aux besoins de rénovation
performante ou encore les innovations en
matière de modèles économique et
technique constitutives constructive
pardon je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous passons au groupe
HORIZONS et à parenté la parole est à
Monsieur Thiébault oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre cela a
été dit les rénovations à énergétiques
des bâtiments est un enjeu essentiel
aussi bien pour lutter contre
dérèglement climatiques mais aussi pour
faire face à la crise énergétique
remporter du confort que ce soit pour
les Français les Françaises en se logent
mieux et effectivement un logement qui
est plus confortable mais aussi en
réduction en réduction parlons de leur
facture énergétique beaucoup de choses
ont été faits dans le précédent
précédent quinquennat on voit
aujourd'hui qu'à travers la prime rénov
nous avons un certain succès s'il faut
encore peut-être recadrer le dispositif
par rapport monogestes où nous voyons
aussi que aujourd'hui les C2E sont d'un
facteur essentiel aussi pour la
rénovation toutefois il reste encore
beaucoup de questions par rapport aux
5,2 millions de logements qui restent à
rénover ce sujet de la manif
massification alors on se réjouivement
des demi-hier 5 ont été adoptés dans le
PLF 2023 pour la rénovation toutefois
nous avons aujourd'hui l'enjeu de la
massification et nous pensons en tout
cas au niveau du groupe horizon qu'il
faut associer au plus près les élus
locaux et notamment les collectivités à
ce titre là serait peut-être-il
envisager de pouvoir mettre en place des
outils de massification territoriaux un
peu comme nous pouvons l'imaginer
aujourd'hui à travers la planification
de la loi énergie renouvelable que nous
voterons certainement demain ça nous
semble essentiel aussi pour pouvoir
associer l'ensemble des acteurs du
territoire que ce soit si bien en termes
de moyens de ressources de compétences
et aussi surtout en termes de
communication on voit aujourd'hui que
malgré les efforts qui ont été faits il
y a encore un problème de visibilité de
lisibilité aussi pour l'ensemble des
citoyens et des citoyens
ce sujet donc il nous semble essentiel
effectivement qu'il faut qu'on passe par
un outil de territorisation il existe
aujourd'hui des plans comme action
cordeville comme centre beau nous avons
aussi des dispositifs fiscaux qui vont
avec ces plans là je pense notamment aux
dispositifs je viens de Normandie axone
de cœur de vie notamment va rentrer dans
sa phase 2 est-ce qu'il est prévu
justement à travers ce plan d'améliorer
la massification de la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments merci monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
les députés monsieur le député vous avez
raison ma prime rénov est un dispositif
d'aide nationale avec une instruction
unifiée qui a permis la massification et
vous avez raison et je le disais tout à
l'heure ce dispositif marchera d'autant
mieux que si nous sommes capables
d'associer les collectivités toutes les
collectivités à s'attendre de
collectivités avaient pris les devants
et était à la pointe de la rénovation
thermique de leur bâtiment soit
individuel soit collectif avec des
exonération d'impôts avec des aides avec
la création d'Alek et des dispositifs
d'accueil de leur particulier et
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
un peu baroque ou perdure des aides
précédentes pour un certain nombre de
collectivités alors que que d'autres
n'en avaient pas mis en place mais par
contre le dispositif national est
présent partout ce qui fait que des
Français peuvent être mieux aidés si au
préalable leur collectivités
territoriales avaient mis en place des
aides et d'autres le sont moins parce
que ils ne bénéficient seulement de
l'aide de l'État et il est important de
mobiliser l'ensemble des collectivités
pour que chacun mette sa pierre à
l'édifice et participe à cet effort
urgent de rénovation thermique des
bâtiments des logements et des bâtiments
publics mais en particulier des
logements et vous avez raison de prendre
l'exemple de dispositif tel qu'action
cœur de ville dans lequel on voit
lorsque l'ensemble des acteurs se
mobilisent ensemble l'état la banque des
territoires Lana l'enrue et bien on a
des effets démultiplicateurs extrêmement
important et c'est sur ces exemples
qu'on va s'appuyer pour demander aux
collectivités territoriales d'être celle
qu'ils ne le sont pas encore être plus
présentes et surtout ne pas laisser
entendre à ceux qui étaient présents que
la présence de France rénove et de
l'action de l'État doit leur permettre
de se désengager au contraire si on veut
aller plus vite et plus loin dans la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments on a
besoin d'action de tous je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous passons au députés
non inscrite
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre depuis le 1er janvier donc le
dans le prolongement de la loi climat et
résilience les ménages sont
progressivement obligés de faire appel à
un professionnel de la rénovation dit
accompagnateur Renov pour leurs travaux
énergétiques je me félicite que l'État
suive la voie des collectivités locales
sur cet accompagnement d'ores et déjà
proposé par nombre d'entre elles pour
autant deux problèmes apparaissent
lesquels peuvent avoir l'effet inverse
de celui recherché premier problème le
coût de l'accompagnateur rénove sera à
la des ménages en tant que président de
la communauté de communes des Herbiers
j'avais mis en place est accompagnement
mais à titre gratuit pour les
bénéficiaires c'est le coeur du problème
en fait parce que contrairement aux
collectivités l'État ne prévoit pas la
gratuité si ce n'est une éventuelle
légère aide forfaitaire de Lana alors
que les Français vous le savez bien
subissent de plein fouet la crise
énergétique l'accompagnateur rénov est
un coup supplémentaire pour ces derniers
deuxième problème c'est que cette
accompagnateur Renov constitue une
obligation à laquelle devra souscrire
chaque ménage donc rajouter un
intermédiaire supplémentaire va
complexifier les choses il va donc
décourager ceux qui voudraient faire des
travaux et pour ceux qui voudraient tout
de même engager des travaux ce
dispositif va rallonger fortement les
délais de réalisation des travaux en
clair les Français se voient ton corps
une fois imposent une obligation qu'ils
n'ont pas demandé et en conclusion je
crains que sans la gratuité nombre de
nos concitoyens percevront ce nouveau
dispositif uniquement comme une nouvelle
contrainte administrative et financière
comme souvent le gouvernement affiche
une belle posture de principe mais qui
n'atteindra pas l'objectif escompté
c'est-à-dire que les Français engageront
peu ou pas de travaux ce sera donc pire
qu'avant je remercie je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la député
j'ai pas la même vision que vous on peut
pas à la fois
s'interroger sur la complexité la
difficulté pour nos comptes citoyens de
lancer un dispositif un programme un
projet de rénovation et et les laisser
aussi seul qu'il était auparavant
l'accompagnateur rénov il est vraiment
là pour être le tiers de confiance qui
va accompagner les les Français dans
leur projet aujourd'hui tout à chacun on
est un peu tout seul lorsqu'on veut se
lancer dans un projet de de rénovation
on va aller regarder sur internet les
aides auxquelles on a le droit on va
aller chercher tout seul les artisans et
le but de l'accompagnateur Renov c'est
bien de d'être ce tiers de confiance qui
va accompagner nos concitoyens dans leur
recherche
d'aide et connaître les aides auxquelles
ils ont droit en amont leurs recherches
d'entreprise pour faire les travaux et
donc de se lancer dans des chantiers en
étant parfaitement éclairés c'est
l'objectif du gouvernement avec ses
conseillers d'abord France rénov qui
sont le premier accès lorsque l'on
appelle France rénov et puis ensuite
cette capacité à mobiliser un
accompagnateur Renov je pense qu'il faut
simplifier vous avez raison et avoir
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore
différents types d'accompagnateurs rénov
avoir un dispositif le plus unique
possible le moins coûte possible pour
que il n'y ait pas un frein à prendre un
accompagnateur Renov qui serait des
freins financiers pour que chacun puisse
se lancer dans les différents chantiers
qui peuvent être différents quand on est
propriétaire d'un bien individuel ou
lorsqu'on habite dans une copropriété et
donc on a un appartement et
l'accompagnateur rénove et les Amos
copro devront être en capacité de donner
toutes les informations nécessaires à
une copropriété lorsqu'elle lancera des
travaux ou lorsque l'on est propriétaire
d'une maison individuelle et bien avoir
des des différences d'aide et de
connaissances du monde entier à la plus
éclairée possible je vous remercie je
vous remercie la séance de questions est
terminée je vous rappelle que débat sur
la réforme de la voie professionnelle et
maintenant inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée mais qui se tiendra en salle
Lamartine je vais donc suspendre la
séance qui reprendra donc en fin de
Lamartine d'ici une dizaine de minutes
la séance est suspendue